[Musique]
Fabricé, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Succintement, Fabrice Éboué. Fabrice
Félix André Eboué, pas de lien avec le
Félix Éboué un peu plus connu. Euh né 7
juin 1977 à Maison Alfort dans le 94,
grandi essentiellement à nos gens sur
Marne. Euh Per Ginéco maire prof
d'histoire, maman Normande, papa immigré
camerounais. Euh trois frères et sœurs.
Bienvenue.
On a décidé de vous faire venir pour
plein de choses pour déjà faire notre
petite récréation. parce que on aborde
comme vous le savez des sujets un peu
compliqués. Vous connaissiez la chaîne
avant de venir ?
Je connaissais la chaîne avant de venir
puisque je suis assez assez geek quand
j'ai un sujet que qui m'emballe. Je vais
beaucoup sur les réseaux sur YouTube
évidemment et je crois que je suis tombé
sur sur du pontel qui fait partie un peu
de mes modèles dans le métier, la
liberté et cetera. Ces films évidemment
et généralement quand il y a une
interview du Pontel qui est assez rare
puisqu'il en accorde peu et qui est
assez libre, je fonce. Donc ça a été le
cas ou
et qui est assez longue
qui est qui est assez longue aussi mais
c'est pour ça qu'on vient c'est pour une
fois on fait pas le comique et j'aurais
pas un quiz avec des où je devrais être
drôle à chaque réponse et cetera. C'est
aussi pour ça qu'on est là.
Et donc bienvenue. La première question
que je vais vous poser comment vous
sentez le 21e siècle
en tant qu'humoriste ? Est-ce qu'on peut
rire de tout ? Est-ce qu'on peut rire de
tout avec tout le monde ? La question
bateau.
Voilà. Méga question bateau.
La méga question bateau. Genre aussi le
fossé.
Euh vas-y, fais comme chez toi.
Moi, j'estime qu'on se doit de rire de
tout. Alors après, effectivement, chacun
ses sensibilités. Moi moi la chose que
je réponds souvent, c'est euh il y a
plein de sujets qui vont te sembler
drôles, qui qui où tu vas dire personne
ne peut être touché par ce sujet alors
que il y a une minorité qui Moi, j'ai un
exemple tout con, c'est bête. Un jour,
je fais un spectacle, je parle de tur en
série, je parle de conflits, je parle de
guerre, de tout ce que tu veux et à un
moment je parle de véganisme justement
et pour une histoire d'une huîre qui est
en train de souffrir et quelqu'un qui se
lève qui est scandalisé, qui trouve que
ma partie sur les huîtres qui sont en
train de souffrir va trop loin alors que
juste avant tu as déblatéré des choses
horribles sur des sujets beaucoup plus
sensibles, beaucoup plus durs. Donc
chacun a sa sensibilité. Après euh voilà
donc est-ce qu'on Oui, on doit rire de
tout selon moi parce que c'est une
soupape, parce que ça fait du bien et
parce que je je crois que si on commence
à se censurer sur un sujet, on dit plus
rien surtout aujourd'hui où tout est
communauté, tout est géré par les
réseaux sociaux. Effectivement que c'est
de plus en plus compliqué euh
en sachant que je pense que l'humoriste
d'aujourd'hui,
ça l'arrange de se persuader qu'on ne
peut pas rire de tout alors que c'est le
cas. Je je pense que euh on peut
beaucoup plus il y a il y a beaucoup
moins de censure aujourd'hui que dans
les années 80. Et ce qui est amusant,
c'est que de on nous dit très souvent
les coluches, les proches, ils allaient
beaucoup plus loin. Alors qu'à mon avis
la censure et surtout la morale, que ce
soit par rapport à plein de choses, à la
religion, par rapport à la sexualité
était quand même beaucoup plus prononcé
à cette époque-là. Ils allaient loin
parce qu' parce qu'ils osaient.
Aujourd'hui, la censure, on se l'impose
tout seul et ça nous arrange bien de
nous dire on ne peut pas rire de tout
alors qu'en tout cas sur scène, on peut
le faire sans problème. Ensuite, télé,
radio, les réseaux sociaux s'y mettent
et les pressions de communauté s'y
mettent.
Comment tu as perçu la garde à vue de
Guillaume Meuris ?
J'ai euh j'ai il faut que tu me il faut
que tu me replaces dans le contexte.
Guillaumeis qui a fait une blague sur le
prépu de
voilà c'est c'est je connais pas tous
les collègues donc c'est pour ça que je
je permets il a fait la prépu sur la la
blague de Netaniaou effectivement bah
c'est là où tu tu te demandes pourquoi
en fait si cette blague mérite
réellement une garde à vue je dois
prendre 10 ans de prison c'est c'est
c'est c'est ça la réalité c'est que si
tu regardes mon dernier spectacle
qui s'appelle comment
qui s'appelle adieu hier si tu le
regardes il est disponible sur certaines
plateformes ou tu tu verras que Je suis
et et c'est ça qui me c'est c'est ça qui
est hallucinant, c'est que effectivement
tu as des sujets euh alors je comprends
que euh on a besoin de recul sur
certains sujets à des moments parce
qu'il y a des tragédies, parce qu'il y a
des des ressentis qui sont plus
puissants. Mais cette blague là pour le
coup,
j'aurais pu la faire. C'est ça si tu
veux. C'est c'est J'aurais pu faire une
blague en tout cas dans ce genre-là.
Donc effectivement la la garde à vue,
non, je je peux pas comprendre qu'on
puisse faire une garde à vue pour ça. Je
te dis mon spectacle c'est limite la
peine de mort pour moi. Je peux pas mais
je te le redis, c'est une histoire de
sensibilité et la différence puisqu'on
parlait du siècle dernier avec les
Coluches et les proches, c'est la
récupération et la politisation. Moi,
j'avais dans un spectacle antérieur, moi
j'avais eu toute ma prise de bec avec
Annie Dalgo sur la journée sans voiture
et cetera. On avait fait des réponses
machin interposé et je lui avais fait
une toute petite vidéo puisqu'elle me
demandait de prendre les transports en
commun. Je lui donnais rendez-vous, je
sais plus à la guerre de Sarcel à 22h30
et cetera. Et donc euh à la fin
effectivement ma réponse est reprise
mais elle est reprise par des
communautés avec lesquelles j'ai pour
lesquelles je n'ai aucune affection,
pour lesquelles je n'ai aucun lien avec
lesquels je n'ai aucun lien. Et
finalement, c'est ça le problème des
réseaux, c'est que parfois même toi, tu
vas juste défendre l'humour, le rire. Et
certainement Guillaume voulait juste
défendre l'humour à ce moment-là et tu
es récupéré parce que quand on dit tu es
un génie, parfois c'est pas ceux voilà
qui vont forcément dans ton sens mais
c'est ça qui est dramatique, c'est que
finalement aujourd'hui la récupération
tu tu la contrôles absolument pas.
Quand tu connais bien ton milieu
d'humoriste, tes collègues, est-ce que
tu penses pas que maintenant les
humoristes sont devenus plus cynique
que réellement humoriste ?
Il y a peu de gens. Le métier, il a
énormément évolué. Moi, je suis je suis
un peu j'ai 47 ans cette année. Je suis
un peu l'entre deux. Le monde de
l'humour, il démarre par un truc que
tout le monde connaît les années 80,
c'est les cabarets, les cafés théâtre.
Ça vient des Deusanes mais c'est aussi
euh le théâtre de Bouvard. Voilà, on va
présenter parler de la représentation
télé. C'est le théâtre de Bouvard. Donc
les humoristes, qu'est-ce qu'ils font à
l'époque ? Ils vont faire les blancs
mentaux, les points virgule et cetera.
Ils sont repérés petit à petit, tu
remplis ta salle. Ça fait du bouche à
oreille ce qu'il existe difficilement
aujourd'hui. Il y a peu de comiqu ça
peut aller assez vite mais il faut faire
tes armes année après année remplir tes
salles et tu avais des émissions comme
le théâtre de Bouvard. Ensuite tu as eu
la classe. Tout ça c'est la vraie
période du café théâtre où tu peux
encore juste réussir en allant tous les
soirs proposer un bon spectacle. Arrive
ensuite la génération Canal Plus
et c'est différent parce que c'est
l'avènement du comique qui monte encore
sur scène mais qui réussit grâce à la
télévision. C'est euh l'époque Jamel,
Eric et Ramzi, Edward et cetera. Avant
c'était plus la classe bah les bigar lié
dieu donné et compagnie
eu Antoine de C
euh oui oui mais qui est pas un
humoriste de scène
et José Garcia
voilà mais qui alors eux qui sont des
humoristes de enfin des acteurs surtout
pour le coup avec José Garcia mais de
télé et donc jusque-là ça va moi je
commence à la allez oui en 98 donc c'est
la période des humoristes plus dont
l'avènement dépend de la télévision moi
je commence au blanc manteau comme ceux
de la génération d'avant je colle mes
affichesignon tous les jours. colle tes
affiches, tu fais le compte devant le
théâtre, tu es dans un une fausse
baignoire en plastique pour essayer
d'être drôle par tous les moyens. Mais
c'est c'est ça qui te forme aussi hein.
Tu tractes, tu as 10 personnes, tu joues
quand même et cetera.
Et là euh il y a plus rien pour les
humoristes. La classe n'existe pas. Le
théâtre de Bouvard, ça n'existe plus non
plus. Il reste un truc qui s'appelle les
coups d'humour. Euh je crois que c'est à
minuit sur TF1 à l'époque. Personne ne
regarde ça. C'est totalement un Odin. La
place a été prise par la génération
Canal Plus et cetera. Donc on a rien
pour exister. Et arrive ensuite cette
révolution je dirais américaine entre
guillemets. Jamel Comedy Club standup
chose qui existait depuis des années en
France. Mais comme ça devient américain,
comme ça devient hype et surtout comme
c'est très instagrammable. Alors,
d'abord les réseaux sociaux, on a
démarré avec Facebook, YouTube et
cetera. Et bah, ça fait ça fait le
carton qu'on connaît aujourd'hui. Et je
te mens pas, je démarre en 2000, on est
peut-être
30 humoristes sur Paris, on se connaît
tous. Je pense qu'il y en a 1500
aujourd'hui, hein. Peut-être. Et est-ce
que les gens ne savent pas, je le dis,
aujourd'hui, tu peux être ce que tu
veux, hein. Toi, euh, ta secrétaire,
agriculteur, médecin, machin et cetera,
tu as un peu l'habitude de parler en
public.
Tu vas faire premier ministre. Tu peux
faire d'abord premier ministre
évidemment tu as un bon 8 minutes. Je je
mens pas. Tu réussis à écrire 8 minutes.
Tu prends tous tes potes du coin,
n'importe qui a des potes rigolos, tu
sais parler 8 minutes. Tu peux, si tu es
malin, dans 1 an gagner 8000 balles par
mois juste avec tes 8 minutes. Tu fais
la tournée des des popotes, c'est de
tous les comédies club machin et cetera.
Tu fais quelques festivals machin, tu
prends tes 8 balles pendant 2 ans.
Brut ou net ?
Il y en a qui seront à 10. Je te dis pas
brut. Ce que je dis à beaucoup de gens,
c'est je comprends pourquoi tu as plein
de jeunes aujourd'hui qui veulent être
comiques et pourquoi ils sont cyniques.
Parce que quand moi euh à l'époque, si
tu veux, je suis obligé de coller mes
affiches, de remplir mes salles jour
après jour, de galérer justement pas euh
avant que je sois récupéré dans pendant
8 ans meilleure anecdote de ma vie. Moi,
je la raconte souvent. Je joue au
théâtre des blancs mentaux qui avec le
point virgule, le café de la gare, c'est
le triangle des des d'or cafés théâtres
de l'époque. Je dois faire une dizaine
de personnes tous les soirs, parfois
moins. Je suis au mois de février à 22h,
deux salles, une en haut, je joue. En
bas, c'est un mime. Patrick côémoine,
lui cartonne tous les soirs, il est
plein à tel point que j'entends les
rires moi dans ma salle quand j'ai
personne. Donc moi, ça fait et il y a
des gros rires en dessous. Un jour, j'ai
h personnes dans la salle. On me dit "Tu
veux jouer ?" Je dis "Moi, je joue.
Allez, je fais le métier et cetera. Je
joue 15 minutes, pas un rien, 30 minutes
pas un rien. J'arrête le spectacle, je
dis je sais qu'on n'est pas nombreux,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et là,
timidement, il y en a un, il lève la
main, il dit "Je suis venu avec mes sep
correspondants espagnols, on pensait
voir le mime." Et en fait, il s'était
trompé de salle. Il dans la mienne,
j'avais personne. Mais c'est comme ça
que tu apprends à faire ce métier. Donc
tu grandis en allant à la conquête de
ton public. Tu grandis en apprenant. tu
grandis en prenant des coups. Donc quand
tu parles de cynisme des nouveaux
comiques, c'est que ça va tellement vite
et ils sont tellement au courant de ce
que je viens de te raconter qu'on gagne
très bien sa vie, voire très très bien
sa vie avec ce métier.
Combien tu gagnes ?
Combien je gagne aujourd'hui ? C'est
assez c'est assez je peux pas te dire un
chiffre parce que ça dépend des salles
que tu vas faire. Ça dépend de par
exemple je je tu vois là on est reparti
avec ce spectacle. J'ai pour l'instant
moi je veux pas aller en zénite parce
que j'aime le rapport mais un comique
qui fait un zénite ça ça va très vite.
Tu es tout seul sur scène généralement
maintenant les comiques, ils ont ils ont
compris, ils se produisent tout seul.
Donc tu peux en une soirée mettre 50000
balles dans ta poche et puis c'est toute
la tournée machin. Donc ça ça peut aller
très vite. Ça peut aller très très vite
effectivement. Mais nous comme on dit on
a fait nos armes. Aujourd'hui tu as un
bon 8 minutes, tu le mets sur YouTube,
il prend, tu peux remplir des zites. Et
les tourneurs, qu'est-ce qu'ils te
disent ? Ils te disent "C'est
incroyable. J'ai des types parfois qui
sont euh toute la France les connaît,
ils vont vendre 20 tickets. J'ai des
types qui ont une niche qui sont connues
mais la niche suffit sur les réseaux
sociaux à remplir tes salles et ces
mecs-là font des zites tous les soirs.
C'est ça le cynisme. Le cynisme c'est en
gros, mais c'est pas que chez les
comiques aujourd'hui, c'est je prends la
caillasse
alors que je n'ai fait aucun effort.
C'est toujours cette le cynisme dans
notre métier, dans beaucoup de métiers
aujourd'hui, c'est le non travail. Mais
c'est toujours pareil. C'est là, on peut
élargir beaucoup plus, aller sur la
société dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui, mais la réalité c'est un
comique, c'est le reflet de la société
dans laquelle il vit. L'AN dur, tu me
parlais de Meuris tout à l'heure, il ne
fait que refléter un conflit d'une
dureté extraordinaire. On a le droit
face à un conflit très dur peut-être
d'avoir un humour qui est un peu dur
aussi. Sinon, ça on va pas faire un
humour de bisounours quand en face il y
a des trucs qui sont extrêmement durs.
Donc donc quelque part oui, le cynisme
il est là. Le cynisme est dans la notion
de il y a des gens qui triment comme des
pors. Moi je viens d'une famille où il y
a beaucoup de médecins et puis
généralement tu es tu es médecins en
banlieu ailleurs. Tu vas galérer et puis
je te dis tu fais trois quatre blagues,
tu mets ça au bon endroit et puis ça
décolle. Effectivement que c'est très
cynique et très décourageant.
Comment tu prépares tes tes spectacles
quand c'est des sujets hardcore ? Quand
c'est des sujets où où il y a des morts,
quand c'est des sujets où il y a des
massacres ou des choses comme ça ?
Bah le on parlait
de peut-on rire de tout au départ ? Moi
le seul senseur le seul senseur c'est le
public. Moi je prends une petite salle
généralement qui qui s'appelle le lieu.
On peut en parler parce que c'est des
vraiment des tout petits cafés théâtre.
Euh voilà euh qui fait 30 personnes. Au
début, je vais roder sur les plateaux,
il y en a plein aujourd'hui, on en a
parlé tout à l'heure. Puis ensuite,
j'arrive dans celui-là, je fais payer 10
balles. Je voilà, je fais payer 10
balles, je préviens, c'est un spectacle
en construction et puis j'essaye. Et
très honnêtement,
mais c'est aussi le mensonge de notre
métier aujourd'hui, si tu n'es pas
communautarisé dans ton humour parce
qu'une communauté rit toujours dans le
même sens et et c'est ça le piège de la
communauté. Moi je comprends, parfois
c'est porteur, parfois c'est très bien
puis ça te permet de t'élargir. Mais si
tu restes dans ta communauté,
surtout sur cette histoire de stand-up
qui est une prise de parole, tu vois,
c'est plus un mec qui vient déguiser,
faire des sketchs et cetera, c'est une
prise de parole. Et il y en a qui se
contentent d'applaudissement de "Mais si
tu vas dans le sens d'une communauté, tu
auras toujours l'applaudissement et tu
sais où il est et tu sais que même le
rire peut être malsin." Tu peux à partir
appartir à une communauté dire "Allez,
je vais aller taper sur celle-ci parce
que je sais que dans la mienne, bah ça
arrange bien les gens. Donc on va en
rire. Donc donc le rire communautaire il
il est dangereux si tu veux. Moi je
pense avoir la chance d'avoir euh
d'abord d'avoir bâti mon public sur
plein de choses très différentes. Je
parlais du Jamel Comedy Club. J'ai fait
des années de radio avec Laurent Ruquier
où on est là dans une France, une autre
France. J'ai j'ai fait aussi des films.
Donc aujourd'hui ça ratisse très large.
Donc j'ai pas un rire qui va être
complaisant. J'ai rien. Et très
honnêtement, si ta vanne sur un sujet
dur, déjà tu marches sur des œufs, elle
est pas bonne, elle est à côté ou elle
est malaisante, 30 personnes tu fais le
métier hein. 30 personnes, tu les vois
comme je te vois là. Là, si je je fais
de la merde, tu vas me regarder et je
sentirai dans tes yeux, c'est même pas
j'aurais pas de rire, c'est dans tes
yeux je sens qu'il y a un problème. Donc
pour moi, le seul vrai senseur, c'est
pas Arcom ou je ne sais quoi, non, le
vrai seul senseur, c'est le public.
Comment tu les prépares tes tes sujets ?
tu vas lire, tu vas t'immerger, tu vas
sur le terrain.
Je je crois je sais pas, je sais
qu'aujourd'hui on explique tout par des
des initiales HPI, HPE, machin et
cetera. Je je sais pas, moi j'ai j'ai un
problème, je sais pas s'il y a des
initiales pour ça, faudrait que je je me
renseigne mais une colopathie
fonctionnelle.
Ouais, je sais pas, j'ai des trucs qui
viennent régulièrement si tu veux.
Alors, il y a un truc qui est très
pratique pour ça en tout cas qui est le
téléphone portable parce qu'on peut
noter en permanence. Donc je note tout
le temps, mais ça peut être un détail de
la vie comme ça peut être sur les tu
sais, je dire un truc que je fais
beaucoup, ça peut sembl être
complètement débile.
Quand tu lis les les journaux, moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les contributions
beaucoup. Je trouve que les
contributions, c'est une mine, une mine
de haine, une mine de désaccord parfois
où ça s'embrouille, que ce soit sur des
vidéos, que ce soit sur des articles. Et
je trouve que c'est ensuite une
inspiration extraordinaire quand
justement tu veux caricaturer la haine,
quand tu veux caricaturer certains
personnages extrêmes. Et là, ouais,
ouais, c'est c'est vraiment passionnant.
Mais sinon, j'ai pas de je vais pas te
dire je me mets en condition pour
écrire, je laisse venir et petit à
petit, c'est marrant, tu vois. Puis là,
tu dis "Ah, ça commence à être
intéressant." Ensuite, j'essaie de de
mettre ensemble les sujets qui collent
et cetera. Et puis après, je commence à
me dire tiens, le le le sujet de ce
spectacle, c'est plus ça, on va vers ça.
Et là, je commence à pouvoir écrire, à
me poser devant mon ordi.
À force de de manger de la de la
connaissance de la splin de l'HPI
humoriste. HPI, c'est haut potentiel
intellectuel remplacé avant, c'était
surdoué ou c'était comment on appelle ça
?
Ouais. Bah oui, tu avais surdoué, tu
avais Ouais, on disait surdoué hein
globalement les gens qui savaient tout.
Ouais. Mais quand tu quand tu dis le
splin, précise ta ta question
à force de te manger des trucs avec des
cadavres de de comment tu fais pour
encaisser avec ton cerveau qui mouline ?
Parce que des gens qui prennent des
notes tout le temps dans les tel que tu
nous l'as décrit, il y a que Cédric
Vilani qui fait des notes comme ça.
Cédric Villeni, tu vois qui c'est ? Un
mathématicien. Je vois ces théories, je
saurais pas en parler avec toi. Je je
vois mais
il prend des notes tout le temps.
Oui, mais mais je je je prends des notes
parce que euh une vanne, elle vient sur
le moment. La la meilleure vanne, un
dîner à table, elle arrive pas 2
secondes après, elle arrive
immédiatement. Tu vois, c'est c'est le
truc, c'est parfois tu as cette
fulgurance, sauf que quand c'est la
quand c'est le quotidien, tu vas pas la
balancer à quelqu'un que tu connais pas.
tu aperçois une situation intéressante.
Donc donc tu la notes et puis après il
faut effectivement faire le transfert
sur scène. Mais euh je je sais pas si
c'est je je pense qu'il y a il y a quand
même quelque chose chez le comique qui
écrit en tout cas parce qu'il y a ça
aussi on pour on pour en revenir tout à
l'heure. C'est c'est quand même pour moi
le métier d'humoriste qui m'intéresse
c'est créer tous les jours. Tu vois, il
y avait eu ces ces polémiques de vol de
van au au-delà de l'aspect euh Mal qui
avait fait ça. Non. Oui, il y a des
comiques qui ont été qui ont été
épinglés pour ça effectivement. Euh
alors tu sais qu'en France le le vol de
propriété intellectuelle c'est pas
quelque chose de très le le vol en
France généralement surtout sur les
économies des uns et des autres, c'est
pas quelque chose qui c'est pas grave
globalement c'est ce qu'on comprend.
On connait le problème avec certaines
émissions télé qui nous piquent nos
images.
Voilà c'est c'est exactement ça. Tu tu
peux tout voler. Apparemment c'est pas
grave. En France dans d'autres pays, ça
allait beaucoup plus mais en France
c'est vrai qu' il y a une certaine
liberté à ce niveau-là. et et encore euh
parce qu'effectivement on construit pas
une carrière sur des un vol de van.
Gadel Malé, il avait une grande carrière
avant et cetera, même s'il a cédé à un
moment, faut pas non plus dire n'importe
quoi. Euh mais il y en a effectivement,
je suerai pas de nom parce qu'ils
m'intéressent pas et parce que Dieu
merci, ils n'ont pas voilà qui qui ont
euh qui ont éclos grâce à ça. Euh mais
ce que je veux dire moi, la passion de
ce métier, c'est pas une fois que les
salles sont pleines et puis que tu as un
spectacle que tu joues depuis un an et
tu sais que tu peux aller où tu veux, tu
vas retomber sur tes pieds, tout va bien
et cetera. la passion de ce métier. Mais
mais je crois que c'est la passion de
c'est la passion de n'importe n'importe
quel métier en réalité, c'est celle de
d'offrir le meilleur mais de créer euh
c'est-à-dire que c'est le moment où
j'essaye la vanne. C'est le moment où tu
peux te casser la gueule. C'est c'est
c'est le moment d'adrénaline. C'est le
moment d'aventure. C'est c'est ça la
passion de ce métier. C'est que dès que
j'ai fini un spectacle, que je je vais
au théâtre, que je dis "Putain, merde,
j'ai envie d'être à sa place et que je
me dis "Allez, on y va et qu'on va
prendre des gadins." Parce que je te
parlais, tu me parlais de cynisme tout à
l'heure et et que moi je dis que à la
différence du cinéma que je connais, le
cinéma c'est quelqu'un qui va te
chercher dans une berline avec un
chauffeur tous les matins qui te pose,
"Tu as un texte, tu le refais 12 fois,
tout va bien. tu t'en fous que si le
film marche ou pas, tu as pris un beau
cachet. Voilà ce métier là. Moi quand je
reprends à zéro, je vais jouer devant
des salles de 30 40 personnes, des
plateaux, juste avant tu as un gamin de
20 ans qui a les dents, qui rent envie
d'y arriver, qui fait un super passage
de 10 minutes. Toi, tu viens avec du
nouveau matériel. Alors, tu as ta petite
notoriété, ta petite expérience pour
toi, mais si tu es pas bon, tu te fais
fracasser. Donc ça, ça apprend
l'humilité. Ça apprend aussi de te dire
bah ouais, tu réapprends constamment.
Euh donc sur cette histoire, pour
rebondir sur ce qu'on disait de de
"Est-ce que je suis un un HPI du
comicque En tout cas, mon cerveau est en
perpétuelle création et et tant mieux
parce que c'est ce que j'aime dans ce
métier. Et et pour en revenir, parce que
c'est assez global, excuse-moi, je parle
beaucoup, mais pour en revenir à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure, euh je
crois que c'est aussi le le drame du
monde dans lequel on vit, c'est que
quand tout n'est plus que capital et que
l'objectif, si tu veux, c'est juste une
histoire de pognon, euh je crois qu'il
devient un vide et et c'est d'une
vaguité absolue. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? le le le vide et que bah l'argent
pour l'argent pour l'argent.
Alors que si ton objectif à moi en tout
cas c'est dire je donne le meilleur en
public pour un rire que j'essay j'essae
à mon niveau d'être le meilleur aussi et
que le boulanger il est surtout là pour
m'essayer de me vendre le meilleur pain
le matin, je crois que la société
fonctionne mieux comme ça.
J'essaie de le faire à mon niveau.
Voilà. Et et créer, c'est d'une
importance vitale et capitale pour moi.
Mais mais et je finis, excuse-moi, parce
que voilà sur la déformation dont je te
parlais parce que je pense que chez le
comique, mais tu me parlais d'un mateux,
peut-être que lui il est pareil. Euh
comique, il fait des blagues de ouf
et en plus il est drôle. Mais moi, je
sais que j'ai ce drame. Alors, d'abord
que beaucoup de de de femmes avec qui
j'ai été me reprochent à un moment
d'être souvent dans ma bulle. C'estd
qu'on me parle pas, on me parle et moi
je n'entends pas parce que je suis en
train de réfléchir à quelque chose. Mais
qu'effectivement, il m'est arrivé, je
j'ai cette comparaison parfois je dis
moi si je fais une balade au coucher de
soleil au bord de la mer avec ma
compagne, parfois elle elle voit le
coucher de soleil. Moi, je vois le sac
poubelle qui flotte sur l'eau parce
qu'il y a peut-être quelque chose de
plus intéressant à tirer pour un
spectacle. Et effectivement, à un
moment, c'est peut-être un peu parasite
de toujours parce que l'humour a quelque
chose de caricatural,
donc tu es plus dans le premier degré.
Or, les plus belles choses de la vie,
c'est le premier degré. Donc si tu tires
tout au second degré, il y a quelque
chose qui est un peu triste. Mais quand
tu le contrôles plus, je je sais pas là,
c'est c'est une analyse que moi je peux
pas faire de moi-même si tu veux, mais
quand tu le contrôles plus, ça peut être
embêtant. Mais effectivement, je suis un
peu là-dedans et et c'est ce qu'on peut
reprocher. Et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
des gens qui peuvent me dire "Mais vous
faites des plaisanteries sur Michel
Fournier". C'est grave, c'est tout aussi
grave que plein de choses. C'est des
victimes, c'est des familles de victimes
et cetera.
Mais je crois que les gens dans le
public chopent l'aspect d'érision. Euh
voilà. Puis on peut bon la phrase a été
cité 1000 fois de des proches he
l'humour et la politesse du désespoir.
Mais mais c'est c'est un état d'esprit.
Voilà. Oui, c'est au moins un état
d'esprit. H je pays de l'humour, je sais
pas, mais c'est au moins un état
d'esprit.
Comment tu gères le le ce côté avec ton
cerveau qui tourne à 1000 à l'heure ?
Est-ce que tu t'endors bien ? Est-ce que
tu te lèves très tôt ? Est-ce que tu
dors pas beaucoup ? Est-ce que tu as
besoin de faire des siestes ? Est-ce que
Comment tu gères ton propre cerveau
et comment tu gères ce décalage que tu
peux avoir les avec les autres dans leur
propre perception de tous les jours ?
C'est intéressant. Euh non, je suis je
suis pas un insomniaque, je suis pas le
mec qui j'ai j'ai une
voilà, j'ai j'ai je je me lève le matin,
j'écris toujours, soit j'accompagne mon
fils à l'école, soit je l'ai pas et puis
mais je me lève et moi c'est c'est je
suis très rigoureux, je suis très
laborieux hein. Je je je prétends
absolument pas être voilà si tenté que
le le
laborieux besogneux
besogneux. Voilà. Merci. si euh je suis
un travailleur, le talent euh je sais
pas si voilà euh je sais pas si ça veut
dire quelque chose hein. Euh moi je je
d'ailleurs je je suis pas ce qui avait
le plus de facilité. Moi j'estime que
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir construire
un public petit à petit, que mes
spectacles progressent petit à petit
aussi mais que je il y a des gens qui
ont des qui ont des vrais fulgurants
dans ce métier qui dit qui qui dès 20
ans maîtrise la scène. Moi d'abord j'ai
aucune formation de théâtre ou autre. Je
suis vraiment un autodidacte et
j'apprends encore aujourd'hui. Donc mais
je suis vraiment un travailleur et même
le travail, je pense pas que ce soit une
vertu en soi. Je je te parlais du du de
la société capitale, mais c'est aussi la
société où le travailleur euh alors même
si c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui, euh
on a toujours mis le travailleur en
avant. Dire c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille, c'est c'est mérité, il
travaille beaucoup, mais est-ce qu'il a
choisi de travailler beaucoup ? et et
moi je n'ai pas choisi de travailler
beaucoup. Mes parents
m'ont inculqué une éducation dans
laquelle le travail a une place
centrale. Et je sais très bien que si je
ne et comme le dressage a été bien fait
par mes parents,
l'éducation
l'éducation ou le dressage, je je ne
sais pas. Mais en tout cas, le moment où
je me lève le matin, si j'ai pas
travaillé de la journée ou si je fais
plus de 3 jours de vacances, j'ai la
voix de mes parents ou je ne sais pas en
tout cas ça a été bien fait mais voilà,
je me dis il faut que je travaille. Donc
donc c'est quelque chose voilà c'est
c'est pas une vertu selon moi, c'est
quelque chose qu'on a su te transmettre.
Est-ce que c'est une valeur positive je
pense mais c'est pas parce que je suis
plus courageux qu'un autre parce que
c'est c'est juste qu'on assume la
transmettre. Et peut-être que c'est ça
aussi qui manque, c'est la capacité à
transmettre les choses essentielles.
Je je rebondis sur ce que tu as dit un
peu avant. Résister, c'est créé. Créer,
c'est résister. Donc toi tu crées, donc
tu résistes. Comment tu fais pour ne pas
euh plier ou céder
quand tu te prends autant de tu parles
de tueurs en série, tu parles de choses
très difficiles. Comment tu fais pour
éviter que ça
ça t'atteigne, ça te ça te blesse ?
Alors d'abord, j'évite moi de les
réseaux. Je suis pas du tout d'une
génération réseau. Euh, j'y vais jamais.
Mes attachés de presse me disent de
temps en temps, faudrait poster un truc.
Mais vraiment, je j'ai du mal, quoi.
C'est pas c'est pas c'est pas ma
génération, c'est pas moi, ça me
ressemble pas. Donc je je suis
totalement étranger à ces trucs-là. Donc
déjà, c'est plus simple. Euh c'est faux
dire que les choses m'atteignent pas.
J'ai pas dit que ça.
Comment je fais pour que ça ne
m'atteigne pas ?
Comment tu fais pour résister à ça ?
Ben, je crois que j'utilise le cerveau
dont son dont on s'est parlé tout à
l'heure. J'essaie de tourner les choses
un peu à la dérision. Euh on on on ne
résiste à rien. On prend des coups au
fur et à mesure. On suce très vite dans
ce métier. Euh et
on on essaie de résister dans ce métier.
On a plein de propositions. Moi, moi je
gagne très bien ma vie. Je pourrais la
gagner 100 fois mieux. J'essaie juste
d'avoir une ligne de conduite encore une
fois par rapport à certainement à des
choses qu'on m'a inculqué et que
j'essaie de mettre en avant, c'est que
il y a rien de plus terrible par exemple
que de sortir un film et tu sais qu'il
est raté parce qu'il faut aller faire la
promo. Donc tu dis quoi ? Tu dis je suis
en train de mentir aux gens. Je suis en
train d'y aller voir ça alors que tu
sais que toi-même c'est donc et et ça
moi je l'ai vécu une fois et dans ma vie
je me suis dit on peut se planter il
faut essayer le le travail d'un artiste
c'est c'est c'est je sais pas c'est le
réalisateur de la série The Wer qui a
dit ça si si vous l'avez vu. C'est une
série éminemment brillante. Je crois que
c'est David Simon, le réalisateur qui a
dit "Le travail d'un artiste c'est
décevoir son public, c'est-à-dire ne pas
être là où on t'attend. Parce qu'à
partir du moment où tu es là où on
t'attend, tu n'es plus dans une
réflexion artistique, tu es plus dans
une création, tu ne résistes plus, tu es
dans une matrice de marketing de dire ça
ça a plu, j'ai la formule, je la refais
systématiquement." Puis généralement en
plus tu leur fais moins bien parce que
le premier coup c'était vraiment un coup
d'artiste et puis après en essayant de
refaire la même chose bah tu te plantes
parce que voilà mais en tout cas tu
tombes dans une sorte de marketing.
L'artiste doit décevoir, l'artiste doit
se planter et et comme tu dis la
critique fait partie de ça aussi quelque
part. Il doit supporter la critique mais
euh se réinventer, voilà se réinventer
c'est c'est c'est très important. Euh
moi je suis quelqu'un qui m'ennuie très
vite. Alors c'est super pour
classique
c'est c'est classique, c'est super pour
métier. Ça peut être chiant dans les
relations. Ça peut être mais euh j'ai
j'ai besoin d'essayer de me réinventer à
chaque fois.
Tu as regardé le gouvernement un petit
peu ? Tu regardes les politiques ? Euh
ouais, je je je regarde il c'est des
comiques non ?
Ah bah moi j'ai aucun doute là-dessus
depuis longtemps. J'ai j'ai parce que
j'ai j'ai fait beaucoup de télévision.
Moi, j'ai bossé sur un talk show juste
avant les réseaux sociaux, tant mieux.
D'ailleurs, euh à l'époque chez Marc
Olivier Fogiel, euh quand tu fais un
talk show de cette importance où il y a
un politique toutes les semaines, tu les
côtoies dans les loges. J'ai vu puis
c'était l'époque de politique avec un
peu plus de carrure qu'aujourd'hui. He
j'ai croisé des Pasquis, des gens comme
ça, donc c'était déjà les gens
l'ancienne génération. Mais j'ai entendu
des conversations, j'ai vu la façon de
faire et tout d'un coup, je me suis dit
mais en fait, ces gens-là font quasiment
le même métier que nous. Euh
c'est-à-dire que on vient vendre des
billets, ils viennent chercher des voix.
Sauf qu'à la limite nous à la fin les
gens ils peuvent rigoler, ce qui est
très rare avec eux. Ensuite euh nous il
y a il y a un un travail qui est fait en
amont. Eux c'est juste une histoire de
réseau pour en arriver là. Et
effectivement moi je je suis plus du
tout euh euh je je prends et et tu l'as
très bien dit, les politiques sont des
comiques. C'est un jeu de de votre ville
en permanence. Tu vois bien ceux qui
s'en vont, ceux qui reviennent. Euh à
partir de là, tu comprends très vite que
oui, ça n'est que du jeu, que de la
manipulation,
puis surtout on on le sait très bien,
mais ça c'est c'est pas enfin si je je
le dis aujourd'hui, euh c'est des des
des politiques qui sont au service
d'eux. C'est c'est plus des gens qui ont
une soit une raison d'état. La raison
d'État, elle est passée aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, c'est des raisons
économiques. On on le sait très bien. On
sait comment ça marche. Donc donc je
service du capital, c'est ça.
Au service du capital. Ouais. Mais mais
tu sais, on discute déjà depuis un
certain temps, depuis tout à l'heure et
et je crois que le drame de notre
société, il est là euh et vraiment et et
tous se rejoint, tu vois, on parlait du
comic capital tout à l'heure où où on
oublie euh qu'il faut un travail en
amont et c'est exactement la même chose.
Le politique aujourd'hui qui est au
service du capital fait qu'on est dans
un niilisme absolu à tous les niveaux de
la société et qu'on va dans le mur pour
ça. On on cherche plein de de raisons de
de communauté, de responsable et cetera.
Alors qu'il y a un responsable
aujourd'hui. Je je c'est le le capital
absolu. En tout cas, je suis pas contre
l'argent. Je trouve ça très bien d'en
gagner. Je trouve ça très bien que que
certaines personnes fassent des grandes
choses et le méritent. Il y a pas de
souci. Mais quand ça devient l'absolu et
et l'unique raison de vivre, on va dans
le mur. Et quand ceux qui nous
gouvernent en plus ne sont plus qu'au
service de ceci, bah il y a il y a il y
a pas il y a pas de on est on est un peu
mal barré. Ouais. Tu crois pas du tout à
à même à l'heure actuelle à des gens
habités par
le drapeau français, la la conscience du
peuple français, des valeurs françaises
de je me sacrifie pour l'intérêt
général, je sacrifie ma famille, ma
santé, ma popularité pour sauver la
France, sauver le pays. Alors, je te
parle dans la France un peu de
l'Espagne, de l'Italie, de l'Allemagne,
de l'Islande.
Dans le domaine privé, il y en a
certainement. On avait eu quelqu'un qui
s'est été sacrifié, je crois, dans un
hypermarché pour aller sauver une une
personne qui était prise en otage par un
terroriste, monsieur Beltram. Voilà.
Donc c'est quelqu'un qui a une vraie
voilà qui qui avait une vraie conscience
effectivement et la notion de sacrifice
peut-être on peut dire d'une autre
époque en tout cas ou d'un autre monde.
Un gendarmerie dans l'armée ça existe.
Oui oui oui oui. Voilà voilà. Mais mais
en tout cas est-ce que mais est-ce
qu'ils sont toujours en phase avec notre
époque ? C'est la question. Est-ce
qu'ils sont en phase avec les
politiciens ? On a beaucoup de questions
à se poser à ce niveau-là. Euh pour pour
le coup, j'ai j'ai du mal à y croire.
Euh mon père a essayé la politique euh
en France. Oui, en France. Mon père
arrive du Cameroun en au début des
années 60. La déconisation du Cameroun,
c'est 62 la guerre d'indépendance. Donc
il il arrive euh il il arrive là à peu
près euh en France, mais euh bon c'est
quelqu'un qui est gynécologue et cetera
et qui a essayé euh dans une
municipalité de banlieu à à Nos
Gensurmarnes euh au niveau municipal. Et
mon père, plein de bonnes intentions, il
est gynéco, il a pas besoin de ça,
machin. Quelqu'un dans le social qui a
beaucoup une grosse clientèle africaine
avec parfois certaines difficulté qui
fait pas toujours payer machin, il sa
donc donc et et il pense qu'il va
pouvoir amener des choses lui à sa ville
et puis il a compris que c'était un
panier de crab même localement
et même localement. Et donc et et là il
m'a il m'a dit "Dis donc si au niveau
d'une ville de 30000 habitants, c'est ça
euh quand tu commences à monter et et et
voilà quand c'est des proches qui et tu
connais et tu sais en tout cas que leur
intention n'est que noble celle dont on
parlait juste avant et ben tu te dis oui
on on a compris. C'est pour ça que moi
ça m'intéresse guère ça. Enfin, ça
m'amuse, ça m'amuse ce jeu de musique,
ce jeu de chaise. Mais en en réalité, ce
qui est très intéressant, c'est je me
pose même la question de est-ce que des
gens sont encore dup où est-ce qu'on va
voter par droit civique mais en par par
conscience civique mais en sachant très
bien qu'au final se fout de notre gueule
et je crois que beaucoup de gens
finalement quand quand tu écoutes disent
oui, on le sait. Voilà, il y a il y a
plus de mystère autour de ça.
Quand Bruno Lomer annonce l'année
dernière qu'il y aura pas d'augmentation
de 10 % de plus de 10 %
euh début début 2024 et qui nous fait
une augmentation de 9,8 %. Oui
ou oui oui oui.
Et c'est un sketch.
Oui c'est le ben c'est mais mais s'il
est si vous l'invitez prochainement à ma
place. On on l'a déjà invité Bruno Lomè
mais il sait qu'on va le réduire on va
réduire son raisonnement à l'état de
pochoir.
On va le vaporiser.
Moi, j'ai fait un plateau avec lui.
C'est vrai qu'il parle très bien mais
c'est vraiment le discours très
étatique. On sent je crois que c'est
Lena qui l'a fait mais mais on sent que
c'est un discours très bien appris et
cetera, mais vraiment j'ai moi j'ai
vraiment une aversion pour le politique
en général he et c'est pas une histoire
de parti ou autre, je m'en contrefous.
J'ai une aversion pour tout ce système
parce que je trouve alors je connais un
peu celui en France en tout cas, je
trouve vraiment que c'est se se [__]
de la gueule des Français. C'est c'est
pas pour faire un mot très démago,
facile et cetera. Je les ai côtoyé en
fait euh alors via mon père l'histoire
que je vous ai raconté, mais moi je les
ai côtoyé sur le plateau, j'ai vu des
débats et cetera.
Donc quand tu les côtoies en coulisse
machin, j'ai été en fait ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a interpellé c'est que le discours
quand on sort du plateau et qu'on
rejoint nos attachés de presse nous
comiqu et bien les politiques quand ils
rejoignent leurs conseillers en
communication ont exactement les mêmes
méthodes que nous. J'ai été bon mais ton
ton objectif toi c'était pas faire
marrer le le c'est pas vendre des
billets d'un spectacle comique. C'est
que les gens aillent mieux, c'est que le
pays aille mieux et cetera. Donc quand
tu vois ça, quand tu as été dedans,
c'est c'est pas possible. C'est pas
possible. Effectivement, le le cynisme
est trop fort pour que tu puisses te
dire euh non, c'est pas possible.
Ta pire expérience de bruit de couloir
comme ça après un une émission où le
truc qui t'a le plus choqué, tu es pas
obligé de donner le nom mais juste
Non, je peux pas donner de nom parce
qu'effectivement
bah c'était c'est c'est un politique
en qui qui est qui qui devait avoir un
procès très bientôt.
Il est toujours sur le marché.
Ah non non, il est plus sur le marché.
qui a dit en gros oh bah on va graisser
la pâte à un juge qui a été très
explicite au maquillage mais mais qu'il
ait voulu fanfaron ou non je un
politique n'a pas le droit de dire ça
voilà les comiques peuvent dire
certaines choses parce que allez on peut
toujours dire c'est de l'humour et
cetera, mais un comique surtout je
dirais dans une place un politique
pardon surtout dans dans une place
publique il a un droit de réserve pour
moi et ce qui était dit en plus étant
donné le pédigré de la personne on peut
se poser beaucoup de questions.
Ah ouais, tu parlais du du fait que la
France se dirigeait vers un mur. Comment
ça se matérialise ? Comment tu le vois ?
Comment tu le perçois ? Donne-nous,
offre-nous en fait tes sondes, ta façon
de percevoir la société.
Chez un comic, c'est
c'est assez intéressant. D'abord, comme
je te dis, le le comic selon moi est le
reflet de la société dans laquelle il
vit, tout simplement. Euh et je t'ai
parlé du fait que les comiques se
communautarisent
et c'est pour ça qu'on va rejoindre à un
moment à mon avis cette histoire de
capital absolu. c'est qu'il y a jamais
eu cette de de tant de de de
communautarisation des comiques en
France
et qu'en réalité c'est un truc très
américain la pensée communautaire
surtout
l'Américain et ils le disent d'ailleurs,
ma communauté et cetera, ils ont une
communauté qui peut être religieuse, qui
peut être de couleur et cetera. Euh mais
ce qui est dramatique, c'est que au bout
d'un moment, tu ris comme tu penses
communauté. Et et moi souvent étant
donné que je suis métisse, certaines
certains vont vouloir me rattacher à la
communauté noire. Moi je dis je n'ai pas
de pensée communautaire parce que
d'abord je suis un artiste, donc je suis
un homme libre et que pour moi il n'y a
pas plus fénéant que la pensée
communautaire. C'est-à-dire que tu
t'empêches de penser puisque ta
communauté va penser à ta place. Et
quand on parle de communauté, je parlais
de ma couleur, mais les politiques sont
pareils. Beaucoup euh c'est ma
communauté politique pense comme ça,
donc je pense comme ça. Ça rend l'homme
extrêmement fénéant. Déjà, ça empêche de
penser, ça empêche d'avoir euh d'avoir
tes opinions sur tel ou tel sujet. Et
ensuite pour les comiques par exemple,
tu sais que tu vas aller sur tel sujet.
Donc ils vont rire parce que ça les
arrange et parce que ça va dans le sens
de leur communauté.
et et ceci s'est dessiné dans notre
métier depuis maintenant allez, on va
dire une dizaine d'années, la
communautarisation des comiques et c'est
la même chose pour le reste de la
société.
C'est inquiétant parce qu'effectivement
c'est un un point de vue totalement
américain.
Alors là je je sais pas je suis pas un
spécialiste de l'histoire, j'aime pas
m'aventurer, mais on sait que la
communauté c'est un truc très américain.
Mais tu tombes dans des trucs
complètement aberrants ou je sais pas si
tu te souviens parce que Rodne King
avait été massacré par des policiers
blancs. Bon ben il y avait eu les
émeutes, des choses assez
compréhensibles après parce que c'était
la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
vase effectivement dans une Amérique
encore très raciste et très polarisée.
Mais ensuite il y avait OJ Simpson qui
avait bon bah clairement aussi tué sa
femme. Je pense qu'il me fera pas de
procès, hein, mais mais
derrière beaucoup de gens, moi j'ai les
amis là-bas parce que noir on dit oui
mais on va le soutenir en réponse
quelque part à la communauté adverse. Et
alors que la France,
on rappelle quand même que les les Nirs
Américains dans les années 20, les
années 30 viennent en France pour la
liberté de la France, pour l'ouverture
d'esprit de la France et cetera, parce
que la France au départ a eu cette
pensée noble quiétait la République, qui
était un truc avec tout le monde et
qu'aujourd'hui on on nous parle sans
arrêt des plateaux de de grand
remplacement de de de menaces de telle
ou telle communauté, qu'on renforce en
fait l'aspect communautaire et qu'on tue
peu à peu la République à cause de
et et et c'est absolument dramatique.
Donc quand je dis que la France va dans
le mur, c'est qu'on est une
une société qui se communautarise à
l'américaine et non pas à l'algérienne
ou je ne sais quoi et et que ça on va
pas le supporter longtemps parce
qu'elles sont fortes et nombreuses les
communautés en France.
Donc ça c'est le premier la première le
premier la première facette de ton
prisme de lecture sur le fait qu'on va
se prendre le mur.
Tout à fait.
Économiquement parlant, tu le sens
comment ? Est-ce que tu penses que Bruno
Lemer, pour ne parler que de lui, euh il
nous met sur un bon cap ? Est-ce que toi
tu vois des répercussions ? Euh
il y a il y a euh bon, il il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sortent en ce
moment sur l'effondrement ou de la
France ou de l'Europe et cetera.
Effectivement, moi mon avis il est euh
moi je viens de te parler de la force de
la République française qui s'étole sous
le poids du communautarisme à
l'américaine effectivement et qu'on et
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut
accepter que la France a essayé de se
dire qu'avec l'Europe elle allait avoir
un poids économique un peu plus fort. On
s'aperçoit qu'il y a tellement de
divergence que ça commence quand même
être un échec.
Puis on se tire dans les pattes les uns
les autres. et les pays européens se
tirent dans les les pattes. La France,
naas, je parle en connaissance de cause,
en tout cas parce que je suis concerné,
n'a jamais réussi
à s'appuyer sur la francophonie quiétait
pourtant quelque chose d'extrêmement
puissant, d'extrêmement vaste. Et je
vois et je peux en parler une fois de
plus par rapport à mon vécu de mon père,
des gens quand même mon père il est il
grandit au Cameroun mais illevait chez
les jésuites. Donc une éducation plus
que plus que Cato et cetera.
Le Cameroun toute cette génération,
c'est des gens extrêmement qui parlent
souvent bien mieux français que vous et
moi pour les plus parce que ils ont été
très schefal sur la la littérature
française. Il était il citent des
auteurs, des machins en permanence la la
sémantique est très riche hein. Vous
regardez des débats, c'est passionnant.
Euh et et et
euh la décolonisation, c'était quelque
chose qui était Dieu merci, inévitable,
que qui fallait rendre la liberté à ses
peuples évidemment. Mais ensuite euh
il y a eu euh il continue à avoir
peut-être même cette France-afrique à
certains endroits et cetera et et le
grand drame, c'est qu'il fallait être
capable de créer un pont pour que la
francophonie perdure. Le grand drame, il
est là. Il y a quand même une langue qui
voulait dire quelque chose. Il y a quand
même une langue qui a été la langue la
la plus parlée dans le monde à un
moment. il y avait quand même une une
certaine richesse. Il fallait être
capable peut-être de de de se mettre
face à ces erreurs, de dire "Là on s'est
trompé, là il y a eu de la violence là",
mais ensuite il fallait trouver
l'équilibre pour chercher à avancer. Ça
aurait été une une vraie puissance
ensemble. Évidemment, ça aurait été la
francophonie, c'était vraiment quelque
chose. Et mon père vient de ces
générations là euh et il est arrivé en
France avec plein de choses. D'abord,
bon, il est gynécologue, il va
effectivement il a été à Fortville en
banlieu alors une une clientèle, c'est
particulier he d'être gynécologue noir
euh en 1974
en France avec tout ce que véhicule le
cliché sur les noirs, d'être gynéco.
C'est quoi les clichés sur les noirs ?
Bah autour de de de
des petits doigts,
voilà, c'est ça. Autour des doigts des
noirs et cetera. Euh mais c'est pas
évident de de s'affirmer dans une
société comme ça. Lui, il commence euh
anecdote j'ai déjà cité, mais il
commence comme remplaçant à Livaro en
Normandie. Euh lui-même me dit que
parfois on on l'appelait pour accoucher
des vaches qui parce que il y avait pas
de de vétérinaires dans le coin. Alors
on lui disait peut-être qu'il s'y
connaît machin et cetera. Mais il faut
comprendre qu'à cette époque-là, il me
dit "On me guidait jusqu'à certaines
maisons avec des lanternes. C'est une
France d'une autre époque hein, c'est la
campagne profonde." Et il me dit "Le
premier remplacement que je fais, c'est
un généraliste de l'ivaro qui me laisse
sa place pour aller en vacances.
J'arrive un matin en hiver, j'ouvre la
porte dans la salle d'attente, elle est
pleine. Les gens me regardent comme ça,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là ? Je prends le
premier patient hein, il sort pour
prendre le deuxième, la salle d'attente
était vide. Donc il a dû arriver. Mais
une autre époque, de toute façon, une
autre époque, hein, euh je je le dis,
hein, moi ma grand-mère, quand ma mère
se met avec mon père, ma grand-mère
Normandie profonde, elle pleure toutes
les larmes de son corps. C'est un drame.
C'est un beaumont en auge, un village de
120 habitants à côté de Pont l'Évêque.
Vous imaginez le Cameroun qui débarque
pour le mariage là-bas. Pour ma
grand-mère, c'était inimaginable.
C'était le le drame de sa vie. Puis
après, les petits enfants sont arrivés
et cetera. C'est c'est c'est la belle
histoire de la vie aussi. Euh voilà. Et
puis paix à son âme et et voilà. Et et
et on l'a aimé. plus que n'importe
quelle grand-mère. Mais mais ce que je
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est pour
revenir à la francophonie, c'est
un vrai effort d'intégration de venir du
Cameroun de là, d'arriver dans la France
profonde, de s'élever, d'arriver
d'élever quatre enfants, de se mettre à
nos gens sur Mar de tenter de s'intégrer
à la vie politique française
et d'arriver
malgré tout chez ces gens-là qui ont
tout fait pour aller dans ce sens-là. Et
je parle de sens de la francophonie
parce qu'il est toujours resté
camerounais, c'est normal quand tu vis
les 20 premières années quelque part.
Mais d'aller dans le sens malgré tout de
cette francophonie et cetera et d'avoir
à la fin un ressenti, c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est qui a pas marché
quelque part.
C'est un gâchi phénoménal.
Mais oui, parce que là, on peut pas
parler de délinquence, des clichés
habituels, de machin. Là, on peut pas
faire plus un sans faute que mon père.
Et pourquoi à la fin, il y a quand même
un ressenti alors qu'il arrive avec une
culture, des bases communes et cetera.
C'est c'est là où il faut se poser des
questions et et c'est très triste hein
les les immigrés de cette génération à
écouter si vous avez l'occasion d'en ça
ça ça fout les boules parce que vous
voyez tout l'effort
euh pour à la fin dire il y a des choses
qui il y a eu un ascenseur de verre et
et il y a eu pardon un plafond de verre
et et et il faut le dire quand même
ascenseur de haine tu as dit
non j'ai dit un ascenseur de vert j'ai
fait un avalgame entre l'ascenseur et le
le plafond mais c'est le plafond de vert
pardon Mais mais et moi je suis alors le
discours victimaire, il y a rien que je
déteste plus que ça. C'est facile pour
moi, papa est médecin, maman est
professeur, j'ai bénéficié de plein de
choses. C'est sûr que c'est plus simple
pour moi. Mais je pense que le racisme
c'est juste une histoire de rapport de
force et qu'aujourd'hui en 2024, il faut
être capable de sortir de ça et de te
dire que c'est plus une histoire de
couleur, de religion, de machin et
cetera. Si tu as un noir, que tu as du
pognon, que tu es assis, le racisme tu
le vois quasiment plus. une fois que tu
arrives tout en haut. Effectivement,
comme disait Coluch, si tu es pauvre et
en plus que tu es noir, là ça va être
compliqué pour toi. Mais mais mais
ce que je crois, ce qui est dommage,
c'est quand des gens ont fait tout
l'effort et qui à la fin il y a un goût
amè et quand il regarde quand quand il
regarde la mer, il y a un truc où il se
dit "Est-ce que j'ai été à ma place ici
toute ma vie ?" C'est violent hein.
C'est très violent quand vous l'avez à
côté hein parce que ça y a il y a une
vraie schizophrénie qui s'est fait chez
ces gens-là et il y a un vrai raté.
Alors est-ce que c'est des deux côtés ?
J'en sais rien. Mais il y a un raté de
la francophonie qui est clair.
On le voit la francophonie on peut plus
l'utiliser comme soft power en Afrique.
On s'est fait boter le cul par les
Russes. On s'est fait boter le cul par
les Chinois. Ben bien sûr.
Et quand tu as un président de la
République qui dit à un autre président
africain, "Bon, il a dû partir changer
la clime." C'est ça, il faut quand même
être sacrément frapingue pour sortir ça
quand même, non ? Bah c'est et mais le
le paradoxe qu'on qu' qu'on a vu au
Niger et et j'espère que c'est pas ça
qui va se
une blague qui a pas été comprise.
Ben je c'est c'est
mauvaise humoriste.
Oui. Ou c'est une fois de plus le
cyniste dont parlait tout à l'heure.
Voilà c'est ça le vrai cynisme parce que
c'est marrant juste tu me disais parfois
les gens les journalistes disenté le le
ton cynique d'Éboué. C'est pas moi le
cynique en fait. Moi je moi j'essaie
juste de faire marrer les gens. C'est
ça, c'est pas cynique. Les cyniques,
c'est ce dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure. Effectivement, ça c'est d'un
cynisme extrême. C'est c'est le cynisme,
c'est méchant. Moi, je cherche pas à
être méchant. Je j'essaie de faire
marcher. C'est çaou moi j'essaie de
Alors, je suis maladroit parfois comme
tout le monde, ça arrive. Mais voilà, le
le le cynisme, on sait où il est. Il est
pas chez les pas chez la plupart des
comiques en tout cas.
Comment tu verrais des solutions
pour améliorer ça ? Alors, tu es tu es
tu es humoriste, tu es un comique, tu es
pas obligé de me répondre. Non, je te
réponds parce que j'avais pas fini sur
l'économie. Je t'avais parlé de la force
de la francophonie qui a été bafouée
finalement par plein de choses et qui a
été mis par terre et qu'on récupérera
jamais aujourd'hui, faut le dire. Euh
on dit tous les jours, à chaque fois, on
nous dit euh le pays qui fonctionne,
c'est l'Allemagne. On sait pas pourquoi
ça va parce que il y a des gens qui nous
disent c'est à cause de la démographie
qui baisse en France. Oui, mais en
Allemagne, la démographie s'effondre
depuis déjà des années, depuis 10, 30
ans machin, même avec l'Allemagne de
l'Est. Donc donc euh moi je crois
et je suis d'ailleurs euh profondément
attaché euh à la Normandie. Euh j'aime
la Normandie parce que j'ai eu la chance
d'y aller depuis
le PV Cvaron. Bah
voilà et et et quand je dis la Normandie
alors je je et puis d'ailleurs, j'ai
parlé de mon père du Cameroun le Douala.
J'adore y aller, j'adore la culture
locale et et j'aime toutes les cultures
locales. Et le drame, il est que la
politique d'aujourd'hui se fait à Paris
dans un truc hyper centralisé où on ne
comprend plus les Français, où on ne
comprend plus les régions surtout et et
tu vois même sur les histoires de il ne
s'intègre pas de machin, est-ce que
n'importe quel Maghrébain de Marseille
n'est pas super fier d'être marseillais
? Je tu tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Et
et et je crois que le drame il est là,
c'est qu'on ne laisse pas le poids aux
régions dans ce pays comme c'est le cas
en Allemagne avec les lenders qui
fonctionnent très bien et et moi je te
le dis avec sincérité parce que quand il
y a eu le confinement, on le sait où
est-ce qu'on est où est-ce qu'on est
tous repartis quand on le pouvait en
tout cas aux Racines des régions. Un
truc simple avec la campagne, le machin
et cetera comme tu me dis un un Livaro,
un pont l'évêque et cetera et voilà. Et
et quel bonheur quand tu es en tourné,
moi mon rituel en tourné si je cherche
un restaurant qui va me servir du local
à chaque fois parce que c'est le p c'est
un des pays et si historiquement quand
même la France c'est un pays qui a une
des plus grandes histoires. Euh on on
parle en permanence de de grands
remplacements de machin mais la France
c'est un creusé de cultures différentes
à travers ces régions. C'est ça la
force, la gastronomie française
aujourd'hui mais Paris ça ça ne veut
rien dire. Et c'est pour ça qu'on s'en
fout. Toutes les grandes métropole,
c'est de l'immigration, c'est de
l'avenue, c'est du travail, on s'en
fout. Tout ce qu'il faut préserver et
mettre en avant, c'est la France des
régions, la France profonde et c'est
celle-là qui existe et qui qui doit plus
exister et et et le pouvoir
surcentralisé de la France, ne serait-ce
que dans les déplacements, ne serait-ce
que dans tous lois bah c'est ça qui qui
à mon avis met ce pays dedans.
L'Allemagne, il y a pas 1000 questions à
se poser. C'est pas une histoire de
démographie, de machin. C'est
la semaine dernière à ta place, il y
avait le président directeur général des
supermarchés Superubus.
Ouais. On a on tu vois à peu près tu
vois un supermarché.
Ouais. Ouais. Oui. On lui a posé des
questions comment il avait vécu les
émeutes du mois de juin ? Comment ça
s'était passé en terme de vol de de
forcing de supermarché ? Qu'est-ce qu'il
avait pu voir ? Comment il il analysait
la chose ? Toi, est-ce que tu as vu ?
Est-ce que tu as suivi les émeutes du
mois de juin ? Alors, je les ai suivis
d'abord d'une manière très particulière
parce que comme je te dis, je ne suis
pas du tout sur les les réseaux, les
machins et un un pote euh à moi m'
m'envoie "Tu as vu pour le petit Naël ?
Mon fils s'appelle Naël." Alors, sur le
moment, je dis "Qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire ?" machin et cetera. Euh
euh et puis ben rapidement je je vois ce
qui se passe machin. Mais la dans ta
tête quand tu vois ça, tu as un enfant
qui a qui a qui a 8 9 ans, sa mère est
d'origine marocaine. Moi voilà, je suis
un péissu de l'immigration, tu vois tout
ça. Ça fait ça fait très bizarre, tu
vois. Ça fait très bizarre. Tu dis
"C'est sa génération machin et cetera."
C'est extrêmement violent. Bah et puis
les les alors les images, j'ai pas voulu
les voir. Moi, je fais partie des gens,
je me doute de ce que c'est. une fois
que tu le fais une fois puis après tu
dis "C'est pas la peine de de venir."
D'ailleurs, c'est aussi le le drame de
nos sociétés, il est là. Toutes ces
images qu'on regarde en boucle, que ce
soit sur tel sujet ou tel côté ou tel
côté, enfin tu t'extrémises forcément.
C'est il y a un moment ou un autre, si
si tu regardes tous les jours des des
choses sur des tel groupe de gens qui
attaquent tel groupe de gens, bah le
lendemain, tu les détestes forcément. Si
si tu te laves le cerveau à ça.
Euh donc j'évite moi absolument ces
images là et euh je vais te dire la
seule image, la seule vidéo que j'ai
regardé concernant les émeutes, bah
parce que parce que j'ai j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait des trucs où où tu te dis,
tu vois, on parlait du capital et il y a
deux trois vidéos qui m'ont il y a cette
vidéo, je crois que c'est à Marseille
justement d'un footlocker qui est
dévasté
et puis il reste un type à la fin qui
est arrêté par la police parce que lui
il prend son temps.
tu vois de pour prendre sa paire de
basket de bâch limite il essaye les
pointures pour voir si ça lui convient
et cetera et et et la police arrive lui
demande ce qu'il fait là et tu
t'aperçois tu dis mais il y a plus rien
quoi. C'estd que le mec ne ne est est-ce
qu'il sait qu'on a pas le droit de voler
? Est-ce qu'il se rend compte de ce
qu'il est en train de faire ? Si tu veux
c'est il y a plein d'images dans ces
émeutes où je me suis dit est-ce est-ce
qu'il y a encore une logique ? Il y a un
type astetin, je sais pas si tu as vu,
moi j'ai été obligé de rire dans ses
émeutes, il a pris une scie à métau, il
est parti siller un lampadaire
pris sur la gueule.
Il s'est pris sur la gueule et tu dis à
quel moment tu as l'idée d'un pauvre
gamin qui se fait abattre dans un
contrôle de flic et le type dit à ses
potes je vais aller signer un
lampadaire. Il y avait peut-être une
caméra de vidéosurveillance de et et oui
ah, il y avait peut-être une vidéo
caméra de surveillance. Mais
effectivement, je me suis posé quand
même, tu te dis euh [__] euh tu
habites à la campagne, je sais pas, il y
a un arbre, pourquoi s l'emp tu te dis
qu'il y a des démarches qui sont qui
sont assez particulières mais euh
mais c'est c'est terrible parce que ces
émeutes, la seule chose qu'on a faite,
que les médias ont fait en tout cas une
fois de plus, c'est de dresser euh les
gens les uns contre les autres et et le
traitement, il est systématiquement
comme ça puisqu'il y a un jeune qui a
été tué là dans dans dans une RX encore
dans une affaire récemment où on a
récupéré dire c'est c'est les racailles
noires et contre les contre les les
blancs et cetera. C'est c'est
systématiquement
euh
moi moi j'ai j'ai du mal à en parler
parce que euh
j'ai j'ai euh j'ai déjà été contrôlé par
la police. Euh alors quoi ? La seule la
seule fois de ma vie où j'ai j'ai pris
quelques coups, c'est un jour de l'an.
On est avec des potes, on est tous métis
ou noir. Je me rappelle, on fait la clé
au drockstore, on double quelques
personnes, puis là, il y a des flics en
civil qui nous prennent et qui nous font
passer un sal quart d'heure. Ça ça m'est
arrivé. Donc je sais ce que c'est et je
sais ce que c'est que le coût de
pression où tu dis "J'ai pas fait
grand-chose" et ça a quand même
peut-être rapport avec un faciè et dans
quel paranover à un moment face au
contrôle de police, face et cetera. Mais
c'est pareil, tant que ça consistera à
dire euh les policiers euh les jeunes de
banlieu machin et cetera et que c'est ce
que je t'ai dit tout à l'heure, on sera
dans un raisonnement communautaire.
Je parle pas de la je parle plus
globalement pas de l'affaire en
particulier. On n pas les tenants, les
aboutissants, mais tant qu'on sera dans
un raisonnement parce que je suis de tel
bord, c'est la police qui a raison ou
parce que je suis comme si ou comme ça,
c'est les jeunes qui ont raison.
on on peut pas y arriver. On peut pas y
arriver. Donc c'est on en revient
toujours à la même chose. C'est à quel
moment on arrive à s'extirper d'une
pensée communautaire et dire je pense
juste comme un être humain. Après, le
souci qu'on a évidemment avec toutes ces
affaires, c'est que bah personne n'est
présent au moment où ça se passe et
cetera. Donc après c'est juste bon mais
il y a il y a eu des choses ignobes, des
cagnottes, des enfin c'est c'est ça
c'est du cyme, tu tu vois là là on est
dans un cynisme absolu qui est
intolérable où en plus ces gens-là sont
invités pour des histoires d'argent. Là
il s'agit de faire de l'argent sur le
dos de de de gens qui viennent de mourir
machin. C'est c'est c'est terrible ça.
C'est terrible.
Ou peut-être alors je me fais l'avocat
du diable peut-être aider pour la
défense d'eux et bon. OK. Oui, mais on
attend à ce moment-là que le procès soit
fait au moins, voir machin et cetera.
C'est c'est c'est
moi je crois que je je je le redis sur
ces trucs-là, euh la situation pourrie
à cause de certaines communautés à
chaque fois qui aiment attiser la haine
de part et d'autre et qui sont trop mis
en avant et effectivement qui ont
explosé grâce aux réseaux sociaux. Mais
je crois que la France reste une terre
où euh les gens euh souhaitent vivre en
paix. C'est c'est pas pour faire un un
un un grand truc de démagogique. Je te
dis ça, j'ai j'ai jamais été de ce
bord-là, mais je je te dis juste que euh
en tant que métese, tu vois plein de
choses. J'ai de la famille qui vit dans
des quartiers difficiles, j'ai de la
famille plus aisée, j'ai vu la Normandie
profonde et cetera. Il faut connaître
aussi les gens. Il faut Moi, la France
profonde, je la connais très bien. J'ai
certains cousins qui sont des quartiers,
je les connais aussi. Donc moi je je je
sais très bien quels sont les échos de
part et d'autres et que dresser ces
gens-là les uns contre les autres, c'est
une connerie absolue parce que
généralement euh euh ça se finit mal.
Voilà. Et puis euh le le le vrai nerf de
la guerre et ce qui produit toutes ces
situations, c'est le blé. C'est cette
histoire de de surcapitalisation des
choses qui met euh et et et du politique
au service de ces gens-là qui met tout
le monde dans la merde au final, quoi.
Cette merde d'ici 3 à 5 ans, tu la vois
avec quelle ampleur ? Fais-nous mouliner
ton cerveau sur les conditions gé
géostratégiques, géopolitiques,
géoéconomique.
Tu vois quoi ? Tu vois un affaissement
total des services public ? Tu nous vois
avec un dictateur à la tête de la
France, un militaire à la tête de la
France. Tu vois une guerre entre les
pays européens ? Est-ce que tu vois une
dislocation géopolitique mondiale, une
dislocation géopolitique européenne ? tu
me demandes une analyse de de
spécialiste. Non, moi je je
très honnêtement,
moi je veux l'homme.
Ouais, mais je vais je vais te dire, je
crois que on nous tu sais il y a il y a
quelques siècles, enfin il y a même pas
quelques siècles fait dans certaines
églises évangélistes toujours, c'est
toujours c'est la fin du monde euh il
faut il est temps de se repentir. Ça y
est. Ouais, exactement. A ça a toujours
existé.
Passe le bonjour d'ailleurs. Sont
toujours aussi polis.
Exactement.
Il fait toujours pas rentré mais ils
sont toujours aussi polis. Voilà. Mais
aujourd'hui, enfin regarde la guerre en
Russie Ukraine démarre de semaines
après, c'est attention avec Vladimir
Poutine, nous risquons un conflit
mondial. Or la réalité c'est que ça va
être un enlisement qui va peut-être
durer pendant des années. Mais en tout
cas, moi le conflit mondial,
je je je n'y crois pas au conflit
mondial, hein. C'est c'est mon point de
vue sur tous ces conflits. À chaque
fois, on nous prévoit le pire. En tout
cas, je trouve qu'il y a
ce coup-ci, ils ont peut-être raison.
Méfie-toi.
Ah, toi, tu penses qu'ils ont raison sur
Je je le souhaite pas évidemment.
Boudin
je le souhaite pas et je te le dis, je
suis pas peut-être le meilleur
spécialiste de la question.
On a infiltré tout ce qu'il fallait
infiltrer. Fais-moi confiance. D'accord.
C'est Cragnos. Bon bah c'est créos
alors. Mais j'ai quand même moins
l'impression que on voit le pire mais je
crois que le pire on se rendra pas
compte parce que pour moi le pire c'est
qu'on va faire de nous
un peu plus chaque jour des moutons qui
pensent de moins en moins, qui
consomment de plus en plus facilement en
un clic et cetera. Et ça c'est le pire
des supplices finalement. Et en te
faisant voir ce qu'on pense être le
pire, bah on regarde le pire et puis
finalement on t'amène doucement puis à
chaque fois on nous fait le coup quand
même. C'est c'est tu tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Attention, il y a un grand
drame qui se prépare et on voit pas que
le drame on y avance depuis des années
tranquillement avec cette
surconsommation, avec le truc de
l'argent pour consommer. Il me faut c,
il me faut ça, il me faut c'est c'est
c'est terrifiant. au choc émotionnel
pour faire avaler n'importe quoi. Mais
bah c'est exactement ça. C'est
exactement ce qui se passe. Donc la
menace pour qu'au final bah on a
compris, on consomme, on consomme, on
consomme, les plus riches sont toujours
plus riches, les plus beaux sont
toujours plus. C'est c'est c'est bête de
dire ça. Alors, je suis un privilégié et
et je l'entends tout à fait, mais ce que
je veux remettre au centre, c'est la la
capacité de travail. c'est rééquilibrer
les choses et et surtout c'est donner de
la valeur à ton travail, donner un
intérêt et on revient à cette histoire
de de créer, à cette histoire de de se
réinventer et et il est temps de se
réinventer parce que pour moi le le
drame qui nous guettete, c'est de
devenir des moutons de consommation.
Est-ce que est-ce que certains tirent
réellement les ficelles de tout ça ?
Même pas.
Ou est-ce que ça se fait tout seul ? Et
c'est ça, c'est ça qui est dramatique.
On
appelle ça la théorie du planqueton.
C'est oui oui mais c'est ce que je pense
aussi parce qu'après tu tombes dans les
théories très complottives. Moi je n'y
crois pas. Je crois qu' là le monde
s'est mis en marche comme ça et il
avance tout seul.
Euh voilà. Bah écoute, tu m'expliqueras
mais là je crois que ça ça ressemble
plus à ça.
On parlait de religion. Euh euh est-ce
que tu as un ami imaginaire ? Est-ce que
tu crois en quelque chose en Dieu ou ou
la science a tué Dieu ou ou Dieu a tué
Non
non. L'ami imaginaire, je l'ai parce que
j'ai grandi là-dedans. Moi, je t'ai dit
mon père est élevé par les jésuites,
donc c'est les plus donc il m'a
obligatoirement, ils sont très tolérant.
Non, il ils sont d'abord souvent très
cultivés, ils sont très ouverts,
très guerriers.
Voilà. Voilà. Effectivement, mais bon,
c'est c'est un ordre religieux quand
même assez bon voilà, les
je sais pas si strict c'est le mot
machin et cetera mais assez sur le dogme
en tout cas. Mais moi, j'ai j'ai été euh
donc élevé là-dedans avec l'église tous
les dimanches, les comme je dis, j'ai
j'ai tous mes diplômes à école câau
privé, j'ai fait enfant de cœur, je je
les ai tous euh et
en latin en latin ?
J'ai fait un peu de messe en latin
effectivement, j'ai fait et c'est
une nominée patrie.
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Alors, je les
connais pas mais j'ai même été dans des
églises en latin, ce qui est ce qui est
très paradoxal parce que ce sont des des
milieux très à droite, hein. et je me
retrouvais parfois être le seul le seul
élève de couleur ou le seul voilà ou la
seule famille de couleur dans l'église
et cetera parce que ce sont souvent
c'est souvent lié à des milieux très à
droite et
et donc donc moi j'ai j'ai baigné
effectivement dans cette histoire de de
religion de catholicisme.
Je te dirais pas que je en fait ce que
je pense c'est quand tu as baigné
là-dedans toute ta vie, tu ne peux
jamais en ressortir
en n'ayant plus la foi, en ne croyant
plus et tant mieux. D'ailleurs, j'ai
parlé peut-être jusqu'à maintenant de ma
foi d'artiste, mais dès que je fais
quelque chose, j'ai toujours un garde
fou parce qu'on me l'a tellement rabâché
de toutes les manières et cetera. Alors,
je sais pas si on peut parler de sens du
bien, de sens moral, j'aime pas ces
mots.
Protéger les plus faibles, tendre la
main. Exactement. La notion de partage,
la notion de Alors je je moi j'accepte
beaucoup de critiques. Je suis
certainement pas le mec le plus
sympathique du monde. Je suis
certainement Non mais marrant et
sympathique c'est pas la même chose.
Ouais merci. Mais mais je pense être
quelqu'un de juste. J'ai parlé de
travail de machin de juste, de
travailleur et et je pense savoir
voilà la la notion de partage aussi ou
d'essayer que que les gens à côté de moi
soient au mieux. Voilà. Après, j'ai
certainement beaucoup de défauts. Je
suis très égocentrique. Je suis un
comique qui fait du one man show. Je
pense aussi beaucoup à ma gueule par
moment. Mais j'essaie en tout cas euh
mais en tout cas ce qu'on m'a inculqué
est toujours là dans un petit coin de ma
tête. Donc je sais pas si c'est un ami
imaginaire. Euh mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est quand tu grandis dans le
catholicisme dans lequel j'ai grandi,
moi, tu tu t'en tu t'en tuen sors. Je
sais pas si c'est le mot, mais en tout
cas euh voilà l'histoire de la foi
chrétienne avec ce qu'on appelle alors
disons le grand mot, mais les valeurs
chrétiennes euh
que certains ont oublié,
que certains ont oublié ou que certains
ont transformé. En tout cas euh je
marche avec de toute façon.
On parle un autre sujet qui vient de
m'être qu'on vient de me jeter dans
l'oreille. Euh qu'est-ce que tu penses
de ceux qui critiquent l'appropriation
culturelle ?
Je je alors là ça fait partie des trucs.
C'est marrant parce que j'avais un
spectacle où je me moquais des rasta
blancs. Euh mais je me moquais des
gentiment des rast des rasta blanc avec
le leur
sais tu sais que dans de semaines on va
recevoir un rasta.
Un rasta mais qui est
noir.
Qui est noir celui-là ? D'accord. Non
mais je m'en moquais mais gentiment.
Pas rasta d'ailleurs. Tu sais que c'est
une religion.
Oui, c'est une religion le rasta farisme
bien sûr. Euh euh mais moi je m'en
moquais gentiment le voir dans les fêtes
un peu voilà avec les les lox machin et
cetera. Moi moi alors vraiment ce tru-là
je suis passé complèt là vraiment.
Alors, je je sais que ça se rapproche
pas mal du walisme et compagnie, mais là
vraiment euh bah d'ailleurs, j'en parle
quand même beaucoup de de dans mon
dernier spectacle, hein. Euh non, non,
mais c'est et et la phrase que je dis
c'est euh euh cette société où la
moindre différence devient une
revendication, moi je je n'en peux plus
en fait. C'est euh tout ce qu'on a vécu
ne peut pas être revendication parce que
on l'a un peu mal vécu un moment ou un
autre. toutes ces petites souffrances
mais mais le drame de la communauté, je
te le redis. Et quand je parle de la
bande, c'est-à-dire que ma petite
souffrance après des années, grâce aux
réseaux sociaux, j'en ai trouvé un autre
qui avait la même puis 10 puissant, puis
quand on commence à être 1000, j'ai
l'impression que ma souffrance, elle
compte vraiment et que c'est un truc
qu'il faudrait changer. T'explique la
bande à DD. Donc DD c'est celui qui est
au bar et qui raconte plein de conneries
puis on lui paye un canon. C'est ça.
Oui, c'est le mec qu'on aimait bien en
bistro. C'était l'idiot du village qui
disait plein de conneries, machin et
cetera. Et tant qu'on était au au
bistro, il y avait les autres qui se
foutaient de sa gueule, mais on l'aimait
bien parce qu'ils faisait des grosses
conneries. Euh euh voilà euh et et genre
la terre est plate, voilà. Puis on
l'aimait bien, on se marrait tous parce
que DD il était tout seul. Le drame avec
les réseaux sociaux, c'est que DD il a
rencontré un autre DD puis un troisè
puis aujourd'hui ils sont 1000, parfois
1 million et que tout d'un coup ça
devient pas juste le mec qui fait marrer
au bistro, ça devient une voix. Et
est-ce que c'est pas de notre faute que
ce soit devenu une voix ? Parce que à
force de se [__] de la gueule de DD,
DD ça reste quelqu'un de sensible. Ça
reste quand même un un mec sensible qui
noit qui noit sa sensibilité ou son
incompréhension des choses dans l'alcool
et que quand DD il s'est rendu compte
qu'il pouvait se fédérer avec d'autres
DD pour vous en [__] plein la gueule
parce que depuis des années vous vous
foutez de sa gueule, il s'est
radicalisé.
Ouais, je suis d'accord avec toi. Mais
mais je dis un autre truc dans cette
partie du spectacle. Je dis le bistro,
sans faire un truc euh masculin, mais je
dis le bistro, c'était un réseau social
avec des couilles et je veux juste dire
que c'était
Oui, c'est je fais pas un truc
patriarcal mais je voulais juste dire
que c'était un endroit d'être humain où
on se touchait où la sensibilité de
l'autre peut-être que tu le vanais, mais
c'est on l'aimait bien d'aider. Quand je
dis on l'aimait bien, on le protégeait
aussi. Le drame des réseaux sociaux,
c'est que non seulement ils se
rejoignent, ils sont bâchés par une
autre communauté à qui s'appelait pas
parce que X ou Y raison et finalement ça
crée des que des conflits et s'adresse
les gens les uns contre les autres comme
on l'a dit. Le le le drame des réseaux
sociaux il il est là et alors c'est
difficile, c'est pareil et et tout ce
spectacle est là. Je veux pas passer
pour le vieux con te dire c'était mieux
avant et les réseaux sociaux faut tout
mettre à la poubelle. C'est c'est pas
vrai, il y a des centres d'intérêt mais
ça n'a fait que effectivement faire
grandir les groupes, les communautés et
l'incapacité à penser individuellement
ou penser humainement. Et la pensée
humaine, c'est aussi pouvoir voir dans
le visage de l'autre, dans les yeux de
l'autre, ses souffrances. Donc je suis
tout à fait, je comprends tout à fait ce
que tu dis quand tu parles de de
radicalisation via les réseaux parce que
il n'a plus le regard humain aussi à
côté de lui
et la bienveillance. et la bienveillance
qui va avec. Ouais. Ouais.
Question internet. Est-ce que votre
fiston décroche de son addiction de la
drogue au smartphone ?
Oui, ça c'est bah écoute,
on est là-dedans parce que j'en parle
dans le le spectacle aussi et je je
parle de je mon gamin il a il a il a 8
ans donc je suis vraiment un gamin qui
est qui est on est à Stalingrad en train
de chercher du craque et lui c'est
pareil que son son le téléphone
portable. Mais et ce qui est
hallucinant, c'est quand tu t'aperçois
que les gamins commencent à être comme
des drogués, c'est il y a du mensonge,
il y a des subterfuge, tu sais le hélas
les les les pauvres toxicomanes, c'est
que du mensonge pour obtenir ce qu'ils
veulent parce qu'ils en ont besoin. Et
chez les gamins, ça y est, tu as une
addiction qui est traduite par "Je vais
mentir sur je vais cacher." À 8 ans, mon
gamin, il lui arrivait de cacher des
choses pour pouvoir jouer le soir et
cetera. Donc, tu es sur l'addiction. Et
c'est quand même assez hallucinant que
pour en revenir à nos amis, les
politiques et au cynisme, il y ait aucun
débat autour de ça parce que c'est
toujours méfiez-vous mais c'est d'une
violence inouie sur ce qui est en train
de se passer sur les enfants. Et on le
sait que beaucoup de gens qui ont créé
tout ça mettent leur gamins dans des
écoles job où il y a que du stylo et du
papier et surtout pas ces saloperies
entre guillemets. Mais mais mais
là là on se pose la question de pourquoi
à un moment on essaie pas de de d'être
d'aller un peu plus à fond et et c'est
marrant parce que regarde il y a 10 ans,
on te disait alors moi mes gamins, il y
aura pas de téléphone avant le lycée.
Petit à petit c'était alors moi mes
gamins, il y aura pas de téléphone avant
la 4e. Là on commence à être en 6e et il
te dire si ton gamin il a pas de
téléphone en 6e, il va être exclu. De
toute façon, tu arriveras pas. C'est
c'est complètement hallucinant. Mais il
y a pire que ça. Il y a le gamin qui ne
peut pas manger sans avoir sa petite
contine sur le téléphone portable à côté
de sa cuillère en plastique pour manger
sa petite purée. Tu as pas vu ça ?
Si si. Bah et puis surtout tu le vois
tous les soirs.
C'est une facilité d'âme.
Ah bah c'est c'est terrifiant. C'est
c'est terrifiant le fameux les fameuses
vacances. On discute entre adultes.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait les deux enfants ?
On leur pose chacun une tablette puis il
y a plus rien. C'est mais mais euh c'est
amusant parce que quand j'en parle le
soir les gens rif
à à 16 ans devant leur leur leur leur
tablette ou leur smartphone. Mais à la
fin je dis mais attendez, on est on est
tous pareils aussi. Et je dis je suis
venu en train chez vous dans le dans le
train, ils étaient tous sur il y avait
un monsieur je dis avec un livre et je
l'ai giflé en disant "Tu te prends pour
qui ?" Mais mais mais mais mais mais euh
mais mais mais la réalité, elle est que
ça c'est c'est euh c'est c'est et puis
c'est amusant que le télétravail arrive
à ce moment-là, qu'on tu vois qu'on
qu'on y aille tous à fond euh et on
rejoint encore une fois ce que je te
disais tout à l'heure sur le besoin de
retrouver un peu de force des régions,
de terroir et cetera. c'est que tout ça
ça rapporte aussi avec la nature
peut-être avec le besoin d'aller vers
des produits qui te font voir
complètement d'autres choses. C'est une
relation direct avec la culture que ce
soit la le vin, la bouffe, tout ce que
tu veux. Donc donc tout ça c'est
important parce que ça ça te décroche de
tout ça.
Comment tu vois l'intelligence
artificielle débarquée dans ton milieu
quand tu vois l'intelligence
artificielle des lions de musque ? On
l'a un petit peu chauffé et des fois il
est il est vraiment marrant.
Ouais, c'est un personnage. Ouais.
Comment tu vois l'intelligence
artificielle débarquer dans ton métier ?
Il y en a qu' on peur. Bah, tu tu as
bien vu qu'aux États-Unis, ça fait même
des des grèves chez les scénaristes.
Enf, il l'évoquent pendant la grève. En
tout cas, il il flippe.
Ça ça m'étonne pas en tout cas que les
les gens qui travaillent pour les grands
studios américains flippent. Tu sais que
le tous les films qu'on va voir sont
quasiment basés sur une grande théorie,
je peux te citer le nom si tu veux du
qui s'appelle John Truby qui a écrit un
livre et c'est un peu la Bible du
scénario et le scénario exact doit
coller à ce qui a marqué dans ce livre
et tous les studios américains depuis
des années font ça comme ça. Et
aujourd'hui sans s'en rendre compte
quand tu dis généralement c'est un bon
film, c'est parce que tu tu as tu as
pris le calque dans la gueule en fait.
Et et je pense que l'intelligence
artificielle va être capable de te
refaire le calque. Mais en réalité, ça
fait longtemps que ça c'est plus de
l'artistique, c'est une règle
mathématique limite. Je ne pense pas que
l'intelligence artificielle dans notre
métier pourra sortir une fois de plus de
de la pensée basique, de la pensée de
communauté et cetera. Je pense pas que
elle pourra être guill entre guillemets
out trancière.
Elle pourra pas être artistique selon
moi, mais par contre, elle pourra te
reproduire parfaitement peut-être à
Marvel parce que Marvel répond à des
codes à il faut pas faire c, il faut pas
dire ça, machin. Donc là, mais elle ne
pourra pas t'amener vers quelque chose
d'un peu plus artistique et d'un peu
plus créateur.
George Carline, ça te parle ?
Ouais, bien sûr.
Pourquoi ça te parle ?
Oh bah parce que c'est c'est euh
tu tu sais moi je fais ce métier depuis
98.
Forcément
plus tu évolues sur scène, plus tu
essayes de progresser dans ton écriture,
plus tu essayes d'avoir un discours
sensé, moins tu es dans l'urgence de
faire rire. Même si alors je déteste les
comiques qui te disent moi c'est toutes
les 10 minutes mais t'inquiète pas c'est
non mon travail c'est quand même de
détendre les gens qui sortent du boulot
et pas plus finalement même si on essaie
d'amener des choses
réfléchir quand même.
C'est ce que j'allais dire même si on
essaie d'amener des choses mais il y a
des comiques qui le font très bien aussi
qui font rire plein de gens voilà juste
en faisant une gueule. Chacun son truc.
Moi, j'essaie d'amener des choses et des
sujets de société. C'est souvent monter
George Carline était un des maîtres
effectivement
pour ça.
Et ce que je veux te dire, c'est que tu
t'aperçois petit à petit, plus tu
grandis, plus tu vieillis, plus tu
essayes de progresser dans ton art, que
tu as envie de faire passer un maximum
de choses, que tu veux plus être
esclave. Parce que ça, on l'a pas dit
tout à l'heure. C'est pas Odin qui a de
plus en plus de comique. Outre le fait
que tu peux gagner très bien ta vie avec
très peu, c'est pas Odin qui est cette
déferlante de tu prends ton téléphone,
tu as 12000 comiques avec juste une
vanne à la con parce que souvent,
excuse-moi, tu as pas le temps de
développer grand-chose sur un truc, mais
qu'on se gave de rire comme pour mieux
s'anesthésier le cerveau et aller dans
la société dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure. Mais mais euh si tu essayes
d'amener un propos et que les gens pour
connaître réellement ton art, à mon avis
doivent venir voir le spectacle en
entier parce que tu parles d'un truc qui
progresse petit à petit, moi j'essaie en
tout cas d'aller vers un truc qui est un
truc de plus en plus poétique et George
Carline fait partie pour moi de ces
poètes et on sort même du du comique
comique et c'est les gens qui se sont
hissés dans notre art au plus haut
niveau parce qu'ils ont réussi à sortir
complètement du rire systématique qu'ils
savent parfaitement faire parce que
c'est un peu comme la peinture avant de
me dire je mets des tâches n'importe où,
fais-moi voir tes classiques. Et ben les
classiques il les a. Puis petit à petit
ensuite tu dis bah ouais je veux aussi
une émotion, je veux un ressenti. Et
surtout parce que je crois que tu fasses
de la littérature, du comique, de la
peinture, c'est faire sentir la société
dans laquelle tu vis et faire sentir ton
avis et ton impression en tout cas parce
que peut-être que notre avis on s'en
fout mais notre ressenti sur la société
dans laquelle tu vis.
Ta perception. la perception
parce que le ressenti tu l'as pas.
Non, tu l'as pas. C'est la perception.
Et effectivement George Carnis, c'est
une une perception et parfois les gens
rient. Le le rire dans notre métier,
c'est souvent de dire "Ah [__] il a
mis les mots sur ce que moi je
ressentais." Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? Et et notre métier, c'est mettre les
mots là-dessus et les gens rient. Mais
il le savait hein, mais il n'avait pas
mis les mots et et cette émotion c'est
la meilleure dans un dans un spectacle
comique. Tu sens que tout la bande ADD
dont on parlait tout à l'heure, tout
d'un coup les gens disent "Je le sens en
spectacle." Ah oui, il a mis les mots,
on le pensait d'une manière mais on
avait et et là tu touches à quelque
chose.
Est-ce qu'il y a les politiques qui ont
essayé de te récupérer ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Genre avec la petite tape chaude dans le
dos. Viens à ma campagne, viens te
montrer avec moi.
Oui, je l'ai eu. Je l'ai eu.
Tract avec moi. Qui est-ce qui t'a
approché ? Je l'ai eu, je l'ai eu de
manière euh je l'ai eu de manière avec
euh certains. J'ai été, j'en parle dans
le spectacle aussi, mais je je le dis
librement parce que j'ai été invité une
première fois à l'Élysée, c'était sous
François Hollande. Il se trouve que moi,
j'ai tourné deux films à Cuba, hein.
Donc euh je tourne euh Casse départ et
le crocodile à Cuba.
Cela dit, comme très souvent avec Cuba
qui a un pays où les gens sont très
éduqués, pas de moyens mais un gros
savoir-faire et une grande intelligence
parce que il faut faire avec les moyens
qu'on a, les moyens du bord. Donc je
tourne de films à Cuba et c'est vraiment
un endroit que j'adore parce que j'ai
créé beaucoup de liens professionnels.
Je peux couper ?
Ouais.
Vous étiez surveillé par les services
cubains sur place ou pas ? Bien bien
entendu. Bien entendu. Et ce qui est
très drôle quand tu tournes à Cuba,
c'est que tu peux tout tourner à Cuba.
Tout ce que tu veux, sauf Cuba. Et ça,
c'est très drôle. Tu peux tourner un
film sur tous les sujets que tu veux,
sur tous les pays que tu veux qui
ressemblent plus ou moins dans le climat
dans Mais pas Cuba. Et effectivement, on
avait en permanence quelqu'un et même
les gens qui tournaient avec nous
faisaient attention quand ils nous
parlaient parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'il y a des oreilles. Là, tu es quand
même dans un régime totalitaire. On est
enfin faut pas être dupe de de là où tu
te trouves.
Tu connais tu connais le proverbe cubain
? Quand il y a plus de trois personnes
dans la dans une pièce.
Ouais. Ouais. Il y a forcément unun qui
fait partie de Ouais. des des services
secrets ouf de la police et cetera.
C'est c'est ça l'histoire. Oui. Bah là
là, on le savait et en l'occurrence euh
François Hollande, c'est Raoul Castro
qui est invité. Donc via l'ambassadeur
là-bas, puisque quand tu vas là-bas,
forcément tu as des relations avec pour
pouvoir tourner là-bas quand même. C'est
c'est qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu en
penses machin ? Quand je dis à mon agent
mais faut absolument y aller, tu te
rends pas compte, c'est l'Élysée.
J'avais déjà été on avait eu la la chev
la la chevalier, on était chevalier des
arts et des lettres pour le premier film
départ. J'avais pas été déjà, j'avais
refusé d'aller me présenter. C'était la
mise de la culture cette fois-ci je
refuse Philippe Petti,
c'est peut-être ça à l'époque, c'est
2000 2012, un truc comme ça.
Voilà, ça doit être ça, je pense. Ouais.
de de mémoire mais en tout cas je refuse
de me présenter et je refuse tout
àintance pour toutes les raisons dont on
s'est dit tout à l'heure avec les
politiques et François Hollande donc
Raoul Castro
je n'y vais pas mais je te mens pas
quand je n'y vais pas et que le soir
c'est le dîner je dis [__] quand même
non pas les impôts, tu as quand même une
curiosité concernant le pouvoir
concernant bah tu te dis [__] je peux
raconter derrière je peux raconter si
j'étais la cour de l'Élysée tu lui as vu
tous les jours, tu as vu Kaddafi faire
son camping, tu as vu plein de choses,
tu te dis [__] quand même je je par
curiosité tu as envie de pouvoir
raconter au pote. Alors j'y vais pas,
j'y vais pas. Et là on est réinvité
ensuite par Macron sur le film tout
simplement noir auquel j'ai participé et
ça aussi j'en parle dans le spectacle
assez longuement mais pour parler
diversité et cetera. Donc le truc c'est
mat
et il y a des acteurs de la divers je
déteste ce terme, excuse-moi, je je le
fourche mais des act
explique explique pourquoi après.
Oui, j'expliquerai pourquoi. Des donc
des acteurs de la diversité pour
regarder le film et que ce soit un débat
ensuite pour parler des de la place des
populations afro-entises
en France dans les médias. C'était en
pleine époque où certaines statues
étaient déboulonnées à certains endroits
et cetera. Donc euh il voulait euh
débattre de tout ça et et et donc euh
comme cette fois-ci mes potes avec qui
je l'ai fait y vont et que c'est notre
film qui qui passe, j'hésite et je me
dis "Allez, allons-y, on va regarder le
film, on va voir cette fois-ci je passe
pas à côté du truc." Et et et j'y suis
allé. Ouais, j'y suis allé et euh
et j'ai vu ce que c'était que le
le président omniscient en fait qui
existe depuis un certain temps, j'ai vu
ce que c'était que le président
omniscient, quelqu'un d'assez sour
le roi.
Oui. C'est-à-dire que
je pense que notre entretien hélas n'a
servi à rien. Très honnêtement parce que
je me souviens très bien, on a parlé du
nom des rudes et tu t'aperçois que tu
fais des plans, tu connais les dîners où
tu es un peu bourré avec des potes
où tu fais des plans sur la comète où tu
peux aller limite conquérir un pays
machin, il se passe des trucs, tu es
juste bourré avec des potes et tu as
envie de de de de perorer plus que de
raison. On
prend des notes.
Ouais. Ouais, exactement. Tu vois ? Puis
on dit on se revoit alors le 10 on prend
la bon voilà j'ai eu l'impression
d'avoir fait la même chose quoi parce
que d'abord je pense que c'est quelqu'un
évidemment il est président de la
République
il y avait la ministre à côté de
l'immigration je ne sais plus laquelle
machin et cetera, mais qui qui était
plus là pour passer le micro finalement
et tout ça j'en parle dans le spectacle
et puis tu sens que il a pas le temps
que là c'est les noirs les affrontillers
puis qu'après on a peut-être les arabes
puis après on a peut-être les homos mais
que finalement on peut pas tout faire.
Et tu vois quand je te parle de de de
trop de de décentraliser,
c'est aussi pour pouvoir faire respirer
peut-être tous ces ces c'est ce pouvoir
en place et dire qu'il faut peut-être un
peu un moment accepter de déléguer. Et
moi, c'est ce que j'ai vu, j'ai dit sur
un sujet parce qu'on parlait de ressenti
tout à l'heure, mais quand tu parles
d'immigration, ce que je t'ai raconté
sur mon père et cetera, si tu es tu as
pas juste tu es pas juste là pour
écouter des faits, tu es là pour écouter
un ressenti.
J'aime pas non plus le terme
intégration, mais de ta place dans un
pays par rapport à ton passé, par
rapport au vécus de tes parents, ça se
traite pas en 2 heur après avoir vu un
film comique, même s'il dit des choses,
ça se traite plus en profondeur. Mais si
derrière tu reçois les Maghrébains pour
la même chose puis les homo pour autre
chose, mais tu bah tu tu n'as le temps
de rien, il ne se passe rien. Donc donc
c'est surtout ça moi qui m'a frappé.
On reçoit jamais les asiatiques.
Pourquoi pourquoi la diversité ça
t'agace ?
parce que ça a été la c'est c'est la
chose la plus hypocrite. Je t'ai parlé
de victimisation tout à l'heure
et parce que c'est à double tranchant
c'est toujours pareil et que
pour ceux qui veulent forcément être
détracteur d'une certaine immigration ou
de fils d'immigré et cetera, si tu
ouvres Science Poau avec un cursus un
peu plus facile sous prétexte que tu
quelle telle couleur ou de telle
origine, bah derrière on va te dire quoi
? Bah tu es pas à la hauteur, tu es
juste un pistonnet. C'est c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec l'affirmative action
aux États-Unis, hein.
Discrimination positive, c'est
Oui, c'est exactement ça ce qu'on
appelle ici la discrimination positive.
C'est qu'à un moment euh
on l'a dit depuis tout à l'heure,
aujourd'hui le défi il est économique et
et je crois que c'est le seul débat
intéressant, c'est comment tu peux te
sortir de la merde toi tout seul ? Parce
que si on t'aide finalement, après on va
dire "Oui, mais c'est parce que" et ça
va faire aussi grandir dans le comic, on
l'a vécu nous Jamel Comedy Club. Moi,
j'ai des potes à moi. Moi, je démarre en
98, donc j'ai déjà 8 ans de galère dans
les pattes. Mais il y en a certains du
Comedy Club, ils viennent là et c'était,
on va pas le mentir, 90 % de de noir ou
de maghrébin. Bah, j'ai l'époque que je
connaissais qui était blanc, qui
galérait avec moi depuis 10 ans, qui me
disent "ça y est, on les met à la télé
machin" et qui m'ont tenu sans se rendre
compte un discours un peu un peu
raciste. Enfin, j'aime pas raciste, mais
tu Ouais, voilà, si tu veux en tout cas
de dire "Mais pourquoi eux et pas nous
Alors donc il faut être noir maintenant
pour réussir dans le comique. Donc c'est
un piège. C'est un piège. Et je dis dans
le spectacle c'est trucs de diversité
si c'est de la diversité
qui finalement pense toujours dans un
sens qu'on a construit pour penser dans
le même sens que les politiques qu'on
cite depuis tout à l'heure, ça n'a pas
d'intérêt en réalité. Si c'est piloté,
ça n'a pas d'intérêt. Pour que les
choses avancent, il faut un peu de
rebelle. Je préfère un mec, je préfère
un Mandela qui se construit dans
l'aversité plutôt que si les blancs en
Afrique du Sud à l'époque avaient dit
"On va en prendre deux trois pour faire
de la représentation et puis continuer
dans le même sens." Alors que face à
Mandela qui a fait de la prison là, il a
dit stop. Et et c'est peut-être un peu
plus fort ça que d'attendre et de faire
l'omone. Maintenant une fois de plus, je
dis "C'est facile quand tu es fils de
prof et de médecin." Je je conçois
aussi. Je conçois aussi. Mais euh
ça ça n'aide pas et ce sera toujours
repris par des détracteurs.
Question internet, j'en attrape une au
vol que je n'ai pas lu. Alors,
méfie-toi.
Euh quand les gens oublient, les pires
choses reviennent entre guillemets. Ne
pensez-vous pas que les gens sont
désabusés et qu'ils doivent voir de
leurs yeux l'extrême droite au pouvoir
pour en subir la substance ?
Ah, c'est de la philosophie.
Euh,
c'est alors euh
la question la question finalement c'est
c'est sur le est-ce que Marine Le Pen va
passer, c'est tout ça ? Est-ce que
finalement à force de d'oublier ce qu'on
est en train de laisser passer
Marine, bon déjà, il va falloir
redéfinir clairement ce qu'est l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui. Est-ce que c'est
Zemour ? Est-ce que c'est Marine Le Pen
? Est-ce que c'est d'autres ? Est-ce que
donc déjà des et oublier je pense pas
que les gens oublient, je pense
le le le souci, on nous a j'ai alors
j'ai du mal à parler politique comme je
vous le dis parce que pour moi je les
mets un peu tous dans le même sac. En
réalité pour moi c'est du
caillou au fond du sac. Oui,
mais la réalité c'est qu'ils choisissent
un thème puis après ils vont le
défendre, ils vont faire leur popote et
puis ils vont faire le tour. Donc j'ai
un peu de mal moi.
Euh
ce qui est sûr, c'est concernant mon
métier,
je sais qu'il y a plein de comiques qui
disent aujourd'hui [__] si Marine Le
Pen passe, on va voir plein de plein de
trucs à écrire parce que ce sera le le
punching ball finalement de dire voilà
et on pourra enfin, il y a des comiques
qui te disent on pourra enfin finalement
redevenir des comiques d'adversité et
plus des comiques de pouvoir comme tu en
as de plus en plus ou des comiques qui
vont dans le sens de la société qu'on
décrit depuis tout à l'heure. Or, je dis
une fois de plus que c'est un l'heure.
Je dis que le comique d'aujourd'hui
devrait déjà
être face à la société qu'on nous
propose et essayer de la décrypter un
peu plus et qu'on a pas besoin
d'attendre que l'extrême droite ou autre
revienne au pouvoir pour ça. Donc pour
moi ça c'est c'est des de la politique
effectivement qui m'intéresse guère mais
je crois qu'en tout cas moi en tant que
comique on doit déjà être aujourd'hui
dans quelque chose qui qui doit faire
face en tout cas au chamboulement de
notre socié sur ce ce vers quoi on va.
Je on l' on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure du
mouton consommateur.
Question internet. Dans le nom de la
rose, le rire est puni de mort par le
pouvoir religieux. Molière a été
inquiété par la compagnie du Saint
Sacrement à la création de Tartuf. Cabu
tombe sous les balles terroristes.
Pensez-vous que la morale est l'ennemi
héréditaire de l'humour ? Et si oui,
faut-il d'après vous être amoral pour
jouir du sens critique ?
Écoute, non, moi je je moi je
elle est belle cette question. Elle elle
est belle cette question, mais moi j'ai
je suis persuadé. C'est pour c'est pour
ça que par exemple il il m'arrive euh de
faire des blagues sur la religion. J'ai
toute une partie sur les prêtres
aujourd'hui et cetera. Euh
avec les fétus aussi, non ?
Ouai. Voilà. Il m'arrive même de de
parler de Jésus ou autre. Certains
pourraient considérer ça comme un
blasphème, comme quelque chose qui n'est
pas moral en effet. Mais moi ce que j'ai
toujours dit c'est je pense que si Dieu
existe, il a forcément de l'humour parce
que il y a rien
tous les connards qu'il a mis sur terre.
Ouis ou déjà euh il a forcément l'humour
euh enfin faut faut voir ce qu'est ce
monde aujourd'hui. Si si Dieu existe, il
en a. Parce que malgré tout, [__] des
fois il y a que ça, je il y a que y a
des fois il y a vraiment que ça.
L'humour, il y a parfois dans des
situation tragique et et on en vit tous.
On est forcément confronté à la maladie
de proches, à la mort de proche, à tout
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui. Si si on peut
pas rire, si le rire est à moral,
effectivement, je m'en souviens plus de
nom de la rose. Mais mais non non non,
le rire il est divin, au contraire, il y
a pas plus moral que le rire. Pour moi,
il y a c'est c'est la plus belle chose
au monde. Euh voilà, moi, il m'est
arrivé de faire des spectacles dans des
conditions dures. Tu apprends qu' un
pote s'est suicidé en loge, faut monter
juste juste après. Et pourtant, tout
d'un coup, tu sens comme le rire est
porteur, tu sens qu'il se passe quelque
chose et puis tuas tu as besoin de rire.
Non, c'est c'est c'est divin le rire.
Question internet, tu veux celle-ci ?
Voilà.
Comment Fabrice Eboué fait-il l'usage de
son temps lorsqu'il ne revaît pas sa
casquette d'artiste ? Quelles sont ces
activités qui lui sont très spéciales ?
Alors, d'abord, je m'occupe énormément
de mon fils. C'est c'est tout bête.
Tu un papa pou ?
Ouais. Alors, je suis vrai alors je suis
vraiment le bout du papa Poul vraiment.
Je je je les critique un peu dans le
spectacle en faisant le papa qui fait
faire du vélo à son fils très kiffes
qui couvre mais en réalité et je sais
pas je viens de lire un article très
récemment très intéressant sur les
enfants américains qui montraiit que les
enfants finalement qui ont été surcovés
qui ont été trop proches de leurs
parents ont été mieux dans leur enfance
mais pas forcément mieux quand il
passent à l'âge adulte. Je sais je sais
pas ce qu'il en est mais je suis très
proche de mon enfant. Voilà plein de
choses ensemble. Ça ça ça prend une
majeure partie de mon temps. Je suis euh
un grand amateur de BD. Je lis beaucoup
de BD de de plus en plus. Euh voilà,
donc euh ça me prend pas mal de temps.
Euh alors, je suis très mauvais euh pour
retenir euh les titres mais je retiens
euh en dernière lecture. Alors, j'ai Les
Indes Fourb qui est un très bon bouquin
pour ceux qui aiment la BD mais qui qui
est vraiment super drôle que je
recommande à tout le monde. Euh,
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que j'ai lu ?
On verra pour les bouquins plus tard.
Ouais, vas-y, vas-y, vas-y, ça marche.
Termine ce que tu racontais.
Euh oui, donc oui, je suis je suis papa
Poule, donc beaucoup mon fils. Dès que
je ne joue pas, c'est assez rare, je
suis quand même très souvent en tournée,
mais je vais enfin au théâtre. Moi,
j'habite dans le quartier des théâtre
aussi pour ça, parce que j'aime bien
aller voir ce qui se fait sur scène.
Donc, je suis assez consommateur de ça.
Voilà, je suis pas un grand voyageur,
par exemple. Je suis pas non, je suis
assez je suis je suis de plus en plus
casagier mais je pense que c'est l'âge
qui veut ça. J'aime la bouffe. Euh
ça se voit pas trop quand même.
Non, ça se voit pas trop. Je fais de
plus en On m'a connu plus plus
enveloppé, voilà. Mais je sais faire la
part des choses, mais j'aime j'aime les
barravins. J'aime j'aime la vie j'aime
le débat. Donc c'est là où ça se passe.
On parlait des réseaux sociaux avec des
couilles entre guillemets tout à
l'heure. Bon bah et des overs. Voilà.
Mais mais mais c'est vrai que euh j'aime
parler depuis que j'ai 14 ans, moi je
séchais les cours. Il y en a qui qui
sèchent les cours pour aller fumer des
joint, pour aller faire les 400 coups.
Moi, je m'asseyais dans un kiosque avec
des potes à moi et on parlait toute
l'après-midi de tout et de rien. On
commentait et et et j'aime le débat. Euh
il y a de moins en moins de gens. Moi,
je trouve que ce qui manque à l'école,
tiens, pour parler un peu de Ouais. pour
parler de j'ai j'ai une mère qui est
mais mais je trouve que puisque y a il y
a il y a polémique en ce moment, Macron
veut absolument mettre le théâtre à
partir du collège. Nous, on veut les
cours de cuisine.
Voilà. Non mais les cours de cuisine,
c'est pas mal du tout. Le pratique en
tout cas c'est pas mal du tout. Le
théâtre moi je trouve pour le coup que
c'est une bonne idée. Est-ce qu'il y en
a les moyens ? C'est autre chose. Mais
les courts d'éloquences
je trouve que c'est quelque chose qui
est simple. La prise de parole, je
trouve que sur une langue, on parlait de
la francophonie tout à l'heure, qui a
quand même une richesse qui est qui est
peut-être euh unique au monde, c'est
c'est c'est vraiment important.
L'éloquence, ça amène à plein de choses.
Ça sauve des des vies professionnelles.
En tout cas,
tu parles de quelle éloquence ? Tu
parles de l'éloquence qui est là pour
prendre le contrôle de la dialectique ou
tu parles de quelle éloquence ?
Non, je je parle de de
l'éloquence à la science peau.
Non, pas du tout. Je parle de la
capacité à rebondir. Je te parle pas
d'un on parlait de de Bruno Lemer.
J'avais toujours très efficient
là-dedans. J'avais halluciné comme je
trouvais que tout était parfaitement mis
à sa place. Et tu sais que le mec il
fait une récitation et que ça a été pris
appris à Sciencep, Alena et cetera. Non,
moi je parle de la capacité à rebondir,
de la capacité à analyser la parole de
l'autre, à l'écouter. Parce que pour
revenir sur une histoire de communauté,
c'est aussi un manque d'écoute à un
moment puisqu'on est formaté d'emblé et
et tout ça, ça fait partie de
l'éloquence, l'écoute et cetera. J'ai
fait quelques euh tu sais euh quelques
concours d'éloquence avec quelques
avocats aussi machin et cetera. Il y a
il y a des choses qui sont vachement
intéressantes et je trouve que ça manque
parce que l'expression orale surtout sur
des générations qui vont être bloquées
sur les les écrans. Euh oui oui. Alors
euh tout
tes fleurettes ils vont faire comment ?
C'est ça c'est ça par rapport à emojis
interposé. Mais tu as raison. Mais tu
sais que ça beaucoup maintenant
séduisent sur les réseaux parce que le
la séduction en direct voilà parfois ça
ça marche plus. Il faut c'est c'est plus
facile de parler sur avec des emojis
comme tu dis quoi.
Question internet. Alors je comprends
pas la question, je vais lire quand
même. Les sujets qui fâchent deux
points. La raclette.
Ah oui alors ça faut voir le spectacle
parce que ça c'est quelqu'un qui a dû
voir le spectacle. Ouais ouais ouais.
C'est c'est c'est tu sais que je refais
toute l'affaire d'Aval dans le spectacle
et ouais voilà et et et j'explique que
voilà que c'est vraiment le la pire
position d'un comique pourquoi je fais
de moins en moins de télé. La pire la
pire position pour un comique, c'est
quand le présentateur vient de voir en
loge juste avant et il te dit "Je vais
te lancer sur le sketch ou la blague de
machin." Et là toi, tu te dis évidemment
que tu n'as pas envie parce que c'est un
type qui va mal te lancer devant un
public qui est pas du tout en condition
pour ça. Et tu donc là le le monsieur
merci d'avoir eu le spectacle mais je
peux pas aller
tout raconter. Voilà.
Il s'appelle affreux Jojo porte bien son
nom.
Question internet. Salut Fabrice, tu
parlais des dangers communautaires. Que
penses-tu wisme ?
Et ben alors ça c'est un des sujets du
spectacle. C'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure, c'est quand voilà la moindre
différence devient une revendication.
On a parlé tout à l'heure quand il faut
et puis en plus qu'il faut s'emparer
même des souffrances des autres pour ne
faire qu'un bloc et dire on va tout
défendre en même temps. Non, ça moi
vraiment j'en ris beaucoup dans le
spectacle parce que je parfois tu as des
mouvements, tu dis il y a peut-être des
choses à en tirer intéressant et cetera.
Celui-ci honnêtement je vois pas où ça
nous mène en fait. Peut-être qu'il
faudrait que je je discute avec
quelqu'un. Je comprends ce dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure, l'appropriation
culturelle. Je comprends parfois que
c'est mais mais là vraiment je pas
grandchose à dire là-dessus. Alleer voir
le spectacle parce que j'en parle mieux
avec humour je pense de ça parce que je
pense que ça prête plus à rire qu'à un
débat très sérieux.
Question internet. Que penses-t-il de la
carrière de Mustapha El Atrac production
indépendante et ressent-il la même chose
que lui et plein d'humoristes ? Mourir
sont mes larmes.
Ouais, il a Mustapha que je connais très
bien parce qu'on a on a commencé à peu
près en même temps. Je sais pas si vous
voyez le le travail qu'il fait.
Mustapha, il est devenu
il a commencé dans tous les rouages
classiques de la télé à devenir un
comique de télé machin et cetera, faire
attention à ce qu'il disait, saadiction
et cetera. Et tout d'un coup, il a dit
il a il a fait une dépression Mustapha
après qu'une femme l'it quitté et il est
revenu en disant "J'en ai plus rien à
foutre." Il a fait des petits cabarets
et cetera avec un micro et il a rechopé
tout un public comme ça et il était
enfin lui-même et il était totalement
libre avec zéro filtre et il a et et il
est devenu il est passé d'un truc très
consensuel. On sentait qu'il y avait un
potentiel mais que c'était cadré à un
truc libre. C'est vrai qu'on a pas parlé
de ce mot depuis tout à l'heure alors
qu'on parle de de comique et d'artistes
depuis tout à l'heure. Et il a chopé le
truc parler de Carline tous ces gens-là
c'est pareil. Il a chopé le graal chez
un comique et chez n'importe quel
artiste. C'est il avait plus peur parce
que il y a ça et puis on parlait de de
et tout d'un coup il s'est lâché, il a
dit bah vas-y, je vais être comme je
suis dans la vie et il y a zéro censure.
Il y a zéro sujets que je n'aborde pas
et je les aborderai comme je les aborde
avec des potes parce qu'en réalité c'est
ce qu'on attend d'un comique.
Effectivement, il a une clientèle qui
est assez communautaire, on peut le dire
aussi, mais honnêtement,
il a jamais été aussi drôle que depuis
qu'il est il est à crever de rire depuis
qu'il est totalement libre.
Libre, tu veux en parler ? Est-ce qu'on
est est-ce qu'on est vraiment libre ?
Non, on n'est pas vraiment libre. Et et
et la chose, je pense
moi j'ai toujours alors je suis viré de
cet établissement avec une mère prof, tu
vois. Je je je j'essaie toujours de
nager à contre-courant. Je veux faire ce
que j'ai envie de faire, tu vois. Et
petit à petit, j'annonce à mon père qui
est médecin que moi je serai je veux
faire les planches, c'est avant
j'essayer d'être rappeur plein de
choses. Alors que j'ai une famille qui a
parfaitement réussi. C'estàd mon père
est gynéco, mon grand frère est gynéco,
ma petite sœur est gynéco. Donc tu
imagines quand même le le moule, il a il
a bien été fabriqué, tu vois. Et etci à
la maman.
Et merci à la maman. Voilà, parce que
c'est elle qui Mais mais mais
moi, j'arrive
à dire non à tout ça, même si si on
parlait d'éloquence, on parlait de
travail, tout ça, je dis merci papa,
merci maman pour la même éducation que
mes frères et sœurs. C'est la même chose
au final. Merci de m'avoir mis les
écoles privées comme il fallait, comme
notre ministre de l'éducation nationale
et cetera. Voilà. Mais mais en
l'occurrence euh j'ai cette base-là qui
me sert beaucoup aujourd'hui. Euh mais
en étant en essayant d'être un peu
rebelle, viré de cet établissement
machin, on m'a mis partout dans des
internats dans le même que fréquenter
Emmanuel Macron et cetera.
Brigitte comme prof de théâtre. Euh
je je je suis resté peut-être je crois
de souvenir 3 4 mois avant d'être viré
aussi de la providence à Amien. Donc
et pourquoi tu as été viré ?
Oh j'ai été viré parce que dans celui-ci
j'ai été viré d'établissement parce que
j'ai fait des lâchés de souris. J'ai été
viré d'établissement euh bon souvent
pour insolence ou pour euh et
honnêtement sep ou h fois j'ai pas la le
grillef systématique mais ils m'ont pas
gardé. Alors c'est pas des publics hein,
ce sont des écoles privées catholiques.
Donc pour dire au public qui nous
regardent, c'est quand même plus facile
d'être viré hein. Faut faut c'est quand
même voilà. Donc donc euh mais euh la
liberté donc j'ai toujours couru après
dans mon métier, dans ma façon d'être et
cetera et puis il y a deux choses qui
sont venues faire mettre un peu un frein
à ça, la notoriété.
parce que je pense que la notoriété pour
quelqu'un qui veut être libre et
d'ailleurs plus généralement c'est un
cadeau empoisonné euh même vis-à-vis de
l'artiste parce que finalement on se
cadre plus, on est récupéré beaucoup
plus, on en parlait tout à l'heure. Euh
donc ça ça met un premier frein.
Alors je je t'ai pas mis les besoins
primaires, le besoin à maman de manger,
de s'émanciper des parents évidemment.
Et puis le deuxième qui te fait souvent
rentrer dans le moule, on en revient
encore, c'est l'enfant.
Et l'enfant, c'est quand même le truc
qui fait qu'à un moment être libre quand
à un enfant, moi j'adorais dire
maintenant j'en ai plus rien à [__]
je ouvre ma gueule sur tout machin et
cetera et et être encore plus rentre
dedans machin et cetera qui à tout
perdre. Je m'en fous, je pourrais le
faire, tu sais, je suis pas quelqu'un
d'argent du tout, vraiment je te le
redis, c'est pas ça n'a jamais été mon
moteur. Mais maintenant, tu penses aussi
à ton enfant et et c'est terrible. Et
puis tu penses que ce que tu fais très
vite aujourd'hui, maintenant il a il a 9
ans, mais à l'école, on lui parle déjà
de son père, de machin et cetera. Tout
ça fait chier. Tout ça c'est pas la
liberté. Tout l'anonymat c'est la
liberté. Le succès, c'est aux antipodes
de la liberté. Je te donne une anecdote.
On on doit faire une émission sur la
couverture médiatique des conflits
armés. Et on a proposé à trois
journalistes de venir des des vieux qui
ont de la bouteille, un journaliste
retraité et deux deux en activité. Il y
en a un qui me dit "L'interview la plus
tard possible s'il te plaît parce que
j'ai encore un enfant à charge et je
sais que tu vas nous défoncer."
Ah tu
tu vois ?
Oui oui oui. Donc le mec craint il et la
la chose pour laquelle il craint, c'est
plus lui, c'est son enfant. Mais oui
mais un enfant c'est et regarde ce que
je te disais tout à l'heure,
le le les vraies joies de ce monde,
c'est le premier degré. C'est ce que
c'est ce que je t'ai dit. Je te dis moi
je me nourris de mon second degré, je v
que ça mais à un moment hélas tu es
confronté et et et quand couche et quand
tu as ton premier enfant bah le premier
degré ça y est tu es en plein dent et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on est que des
hommes, que on peut se raconter tout ce
qu'on veut, qu'on peut avoir la carrière
qu'on veut, que l'essentiel on sait où
il est et que tu es ramené de force à ce
que nous sommes des des animaux et qu'on
est là aussi voilà pour ça et qu'à un
moment un autre bah voilà l'enfant c'est
vraiment le pas l'ennemi de la liberté.
Mais en tout cas, bah tu tu peux plus
faire ce que tu veux. Tu as une
responsabilité qui est la plus
importante dans ton existence.
Question internet, est-ce que le fils de
Fabrice s'est scolarisé dans le public ?
Euh non, je suis comme la ministre. Mais
mais moi vraiment je le dis sans
alors parce que je suis pas ministre de
l'éducation nationale et que je je m'en
contrefou. ces écoles privées
catholiques que moi j'ai faite, celle
dans laquelle est inscrit mon fils, bah
je le dis, c'est une formation quand on
a la possibilité de l'avoir qui est
super et et et ils peuvent me poser des
questions parce que j'ai fait tellement
d'écoles que j'ai tout fait. J'ai fait
des privés, des publics, des machins.
J'ai quand même vu la différence. C'est
hélas le voilà un des mensonges, voilà
un des mensonges des politiques
aujourd'hui. Et la preuve, celle qui va
vous parler d'éducation nationale,
est-ce qu'on a pas le plus grand
mensonge ?
C'est c'est aussi bête que ça. Bah non,
à la Stanislas dans la meilleure école
peut-être de France euh dans une je
voilà on va pas on va pas leur dans une
très bonne école en tout cas voilà
privée catholique en tout cas jésuite
d'ailleurs je crois euh je mais mais en
tout cas euh oui voilà un mensonge.
Voilà un mensonge et et voilà d'ailleurs
euh on aurait pu en parler aussi quand
on a parlé de la ferna des émeutes.
Voilà le le le truc de départ. Ma mère
vient de de enseigner dans les années 90
dans des hubes, dans des des des
endroits difficiles. Et les profs, c'est
un vrai témoignage de de l'inégalité qui
commence dès le plus jeune âge. C'est
extrêmement compliqué, extrêmement
compliqué, voilà,
de s'en de s'en sortir quand tu viens de
là. Et voilà. Et puis
tu tu sais, on parle d'enfant. Tiens, je
vais te parler de tu me parlais du futur
et d'économie tout à l'heure. Parfois,
j'ai une culpabilité à dire plus tu
réussis, même si on est déjà alors je je
vais en fâcher certains, mais
l'héritage, c'est un truc, tu vois, plus
tu réussis, plus tes enfants vont
hériter. Alors que réussir
professionnellement, alors que ceux qui
ont déjà le plus d'argent généralement
ont déjà les meilleures écoles pour
leurs enfants, les meilleurs réseaux
pour leurs enfants. Ils ont déjà vu
plein de choses que les autres n'ont pas
vu. Et donc tout ça c'est déjà un
héritage qui est largement supérieur à
tout ce que tu pourras leur donner. Mais
encore en plus tu veux leur apporter la
caillasse et l'autre il va aller dans
l'école publique de quartier qui s'il a
de la chance elle sera correcte sinon
elle sera pas bonne. Et même la ministre
de l'éducation nationale tu surtout pas.
Bon bah peut-être qu'on a tout résumé
avec c ces trois phrases.
Question internet.
Euh je connais pas l'anecdote mais je
vais la lire quand même. Un gros bigup
de Martin l'apprenti
Stinuper
du nord pour qui Fabrice a été
extraordinaire.
Cette anecdote en temps de Covid
montrerait un peu plus qui est Fabrice.
Bonsoir.
Euh l'apprendi standup c'est très
difficile, tu sais. Je suis sur scène
quasiment quatre soirs par semaine. Si
s'il m'en dit plus, il a il a plus de
choses à nous dire, je retrouverai
peut-être l'anecdote de Martin
l'apprendi de peurer du nord.
Il y a trois quatre questions où il y a
marqué Dieu donné dedans. Est-ce que tu
veux dire un mot sur Dieu donné ? Alors
j'ai j'ai pas de souci à parler de Dieu
donné. Euh comme je l'ai dit, moi j'ai
démarré
vers les années 2000. J'avais la chance
de jouer dans son théâtre au théâtre de
la main d'Or. Comme beaucoup euh un ou
deux de ces spectacles m'ont fait hurler
de rire, notamment le divorce de Patrick
et mes excuses où je trouve qu'en France
c'est un des des d'une des meilleures
choses qui a été faite. Après sur la
polémique comme j'ai dit, ça date de de
10 ans. Le type s'est excusé, il y en a
qu'on dit c'est sincère, c'est pas
sincère. Bon voilà, je vraiment et puis
moi je m'étais exprimé largement à
l'époque sur la question. J'ai juste
dit, moi j'estime que euh je suis contre
la censure sur scène. Voilà. Et et comme
je te l'ai dit tout à l'heure, je pense
que euh l'erreur qu'il a faite, ça a été
euh de mal s'entourer à un moment et
surtout d'aller parler ailleurs qui est
le lieu d'expression du comique euh qui
est la scène parce que c'est ça notre
travail et qu'après il a il est tombé
dans ce que je je critiqué tout à
l'heure peut-être un rire avec un
certain groupe de gens qui l'attendaient
sur un certain sujet et je pense qu'il
s'est perdu là-dedans.
À quand le prochain film réalisé par
Fabric Boué ? Ben écoutez, j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure de mon amour des régions
de de France euh et comme j'avais euh
pas encore parlé beaucoup de ma mère
dans ce que je peux essayer d'écrire ou
autre, je fais un film sur un normand
euh qui s'appelle euh Gérald le
Conquérant. Voilà, c'est filmé un peu
façon stripties, donc c'est un tout
petit truc. Moi, je suis un grand fan de
l'émission
Stripis qui connais pour les jeunes qui
ne connaissent pas
euh voilà, Striptis, c'est du c'est une
émission belge que je recommande à tout
le monde. Il y a des choses qui sont des
C'est pas français ça ? Non, c'est
belge. Ah bah quand c'est quand c'est
libre de thon comme ça souvent c'est il
y a même et pour te dire comment les
Belges vont loin, il y a un équivalent
de stripties qui est belge aussi et qui
s'appelle carrément euh ça ne nous
rendra pas le Congo. Donc donc tu tu
imagines si on appelait en France une
émission ça nous rendra pas l'Algérie.
Ce serait très très limite, tu vois.
Donc eux vont vont au bout du truc, ça
ne nous rendra pas le Congo, tu vois. Et
et c'est pareil, il y a des certaines
émissions, donc on est dans le réel
hein, qui vont très loin. Et tu sais que
Stripties a fait polémique euh que ça
s'est arrêté un moment parce qu'il
suivait un toxicoman et qu'il l'avait
filmé en train de se faire son shoot. Et
là, on s'est dit c'est quoi les limites
du documentaire ? C'est quoi les limites
de C'est c'est intéressant aussi ça mais
en tout cas voilà, c'est du docu avec un
petit côté voyeur certes, mais toujours
suffisamment de recul, c'est ça qui est
fort dans stripties. Et donc voilà,
c'est sûr sur un personnage de normand.
Alors, une question du petit Arnaud.
Euh, trois humoristes spectacle à
conseiller.
Alors, trois humoristes alors le petit
Arnaud, je te le dis, et vraiment je ne
vais quasiment jamais voir d'humoriste.
Son petit surnom c'est Poupoun.
Poupoun. Voilà. Alors Poupoun, je devais
quasiment jamais voir d'humoriste parce
que parce que d'abord il y a un truc, on
parlait du vol de van chez les
humoristes tout à l'heure, mais il y a
un truc qui est très réel, c'est que
souvent quand tu vas voir un comique, tu
peux sans t'en rendre compte ressortir
des trucs que tu as vu parce que tu es
éponge et que tu prends un truc. Donc je
me méfie beaucoup. Donc d'abord, je vais
très peu voir de comique donc j'ai peu à
proposer. Il y a un type qui est très
drôle par contre je l'ai vu en plateau
deux trois fois et à chaque fois il
s'appelle Rodrig. Euh est-ce que c'est
encore au point virgule ? Peut-être, je
sais pas. Mais Rodrig Voilà, ça c'est
c'est très drôle. Si tape Rodrig comique
sur internet, tu vas trouver lui
vraiment il y va, il est jeune 27 balet
mais franchement on sent que c'est ça va
être très bon ça.
Je peux te demander un truc ? Regarde là
et tu fais "Je te fais un gros bisou
poupoun".
Bah mon poupoun, je te fais un gros gros
béco.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous ? Un truc
qu'on a oublié ? Je cherche mais euh
écoute la liberté pour moi c'était
important d'en parler la
communautarisation de la société parce
qu'on le ressent dans mon métier c'était
important d'en parler euh ce qu'on s'est
dit autour de du nilisme de la société
de consu absolu et de capital c'était
important d'en parler les régions.
Honnêtement, je pense qu'on a fait le
tour de mes sujets de prédilection. J'ai
parlé de mes parents, je vais en parler
aussi.
Non, je je
Alors, je voudrais trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté.
Alors, je
trois livres ou trois films pour toi ?
Trois livres ou
ou trois livres et trois films.
D'accord. Je vais commencer sur le
cinéma sur l'obsession de l'artiste.
Ça va faire plaisir à Poupoun ça.
Je prends forcément
Wash
parce que c'est quand même une claque
monumentale quoi. Euh sur donc c'est
l'histoire d'un batteur. Honnêtement,
moi le jour où c'est sorti au cinéma, je
me rappelle ma compagne de l'époque me
dit "Allons voir ça." Je dis "Putain 2
heures sur la batterie, franchement à
mon avis c'est une niche. Euh je l'ai
conseillé à tout le monde tellement
c'est universel dans l'abnégation, dans
la souffrance de l'artiste qui veut
aller au bout de son art. Oui, plage,
c'est euh c'est à à à voir et à revoir.
C'est c'est fantastique.
Je suis obligé au cinéma de te donner un
de mes films qui m'a euh qui m'a donné
envie un peu de faire ce métier qui qui
c'est c'est arrivé près de chez vous.
Voilà qui
extraordinaire qui
le petit Grégoryi tout Benoît Pulv. Bon
voilà à son à son sommet alors que c'est
son premier. J'aime pas dire ça parce
qu'il en a fait d'autres des
fantastiques, mais celui-ci et quand on
parle de liberté et de et puisqu'on
parlait de la Belgique et de leur
capacité à à quoi de plus que c'est
arrêté près de chez vous. Ouais. D
Kenec un petit peu quand même.
Oui oui, il y a dit Kenneek aussi chez
les Belges effectivement qui qui est un
chef d'œuvre aussi. Moi, c'est arrivé
près de chez vous parce que tous les
gens de ma génération, moi voilà tous
sont qu' qu'on la quarantaine machin et
cetera même cinquantaine sur cet arrêts
près de chez vous, on connaît des
répliques par par cœur parce que on a
tous essayé de le jouer à un moment donc
euh Ouais. Ouais. Non, ça c'est c'est ça
c'est une claque. C'est une claque
monumentale aussi pour moi. Et euh un
troisème film, alors je je vais te citer
un de mes classiques parce que un de mes
réalisateurs préférés c'est c'est Sergio
Leon. Euh donc je vais te dire, il était
une fois dans l'Ouest, j'aurais pu en
donner d'autres, mais c'est vachement
important parce que euh c'est mon père
qui nous a transmis la culture du
western. Mon père, il est euh euh
cabronis africain très catau. Et et
pourquoi le western ? C'est très amusant
parce que le western, comme on dit
vulgairement spaghetti
euh euh il y a pas le rapport des
cowboys et des Indiens dans le western
très américain, John Ford, tu vois, John
Wine et cetera. Donc il y a pas le
rapport de colonisation, de
brutalisation du du plus faible et
cetera. Donc lui nous a dirigé tout de
suite vers ça et il nous dirige aussi
vers le western parce que il y a pas une
scène d'embrassade, il y a pas un bisou
dans un Sergio Léon, il y a rien du
tout. Donc sur ces générations
extrêmement pudiques, il savait très
bien qu'il pouvait regarder avec ça avec
nous sans sans être gêné par un biseau,
une scène. Voilà. Et ce qui est très
amusant, c'est que tu regardes le bon la
vrut et le trruant où il était une fois
dans l'Ouest, c'est du d'un sadisme et
d'une violence inouie. Mais quand on
parle de la censure n'est pas la même
selon les époques et selon tes
référents, moi je montrerai pas un film
comme ça à mon fils pour le moment parce
que je me dis mais euh le bon lauelt
truyant quand il torture Walche pendant
une pendant 20 minutes à lui enfoncer
les yeux mais mon père lui trouvait ça
génial machin et cetera. Donc voilà
c'est important pour moi de citer le le
Sergio Léon.
Alors il y a eu une précision qui a été
faite sur l'anecdote de tout à l'heure
pour essayer de te réchauffer la
mémoire. Fabrice était passé saluer le
me faites pas sauter la ligne. Fabrice
était passé saluer le jeune Martin chez
lui après qu'il ait raté sa dernière en
atelier d'impro pour cause de Covid. Il
était effondré mais Fabriste lui a fait
un lui a fait ce geste inoubliable. Tu
es venu rassurer un mou ?
Alors écoute peut-être peut-être non
mais ça m'arrive de donner des petits
coups de pouce machin et cetera. Je
connais la difficulté de ce métier.
Martin je ne m'en souviens pas. J'espère
que c'est bien moi dont il parle mais je
sais pas aller chez lui en mode ding
dong c'est Fabrice peut-être une vidéo
je je je sais pas écoute je je je vais
pas te dire oui parce que c'est je n'en
ai aucun souvenir
question internet est-ce qu'il est au
courant des affaires sur l'humoriste
Sebmia le me standup en cours avec
Florence Mendz en lanceuse d'alerte
non ça j'ai j'ai pas entendu parler
est-ce que tu as trois livres à nous
conseiller
ouais trois livres à conseiller oui
toujour qu'est-ce que Alors je je je lis
pe moi je suis un grands fan. Alors, des
livres en particulier. Bizarrement, j'ai
lu beaucoup dans ma vie. Il y a un côté
très niliste à ce bouquin. C'est pas le
plus simple à lire, mais quand tu prends
de l'âge, quand tu es un peu dégoûté du
monde qui t'entoure à certains moments
et en ce moment, c'est vrai qu'on on a
tous parfois un petit dégoût, il y a
rêverie du promeneur solitaire de
Jean-Jacques Rousseau. Il y a certaines
promenades, c'est par promenade, qui
font un bien fou. Et et Jean-Jacques
Rousseau vous parle de ce moment puisque
vous savez que Jean-Jacques Rousseau a
dit "Bon bah je supporte plus le monde,
tout le monde est contre moi." Il est
devenu un peu parano. Puis il s'est
isolé dans la botanique. Et il y a des
moments il vous parle de botanique euh
il vous parle de l'être humain en même
temps et et comme ça lui fait du bien de
prendre un peu de recul puisqu'on
parlait de de la France profonde, du
recul de la Normandie où j'aime aller
aussi. Et ben c'est lisez quelques
promenades, c'est c'est vachement
intéressant. rêverie du promeneur
solitaire de de Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
Il y a euh il y a un livre qui s'appelle
Smk, c'est tout bête. Euh Smon, c'est un
auteur américain. J'en ai oublié le nom
de l'auteur là subitement, mais ça
s'appelle Smk le bouquin. Je suis
désolé, j'ai un trou sur l'auteur, je
vous le dis parce que c'est un livre qui
est passionnant. C'est du Tarantino en
bouquin. C'est un mec, il a écrit que ce
bouquin sur ce type là. Il en a
d'autres. C'est un auteur américain
assez euh et j'ai c'est Tom Franklin,
pardon. J'ai j'ai d'habitude du mal avec
la littérature américaine parce que je
parle pas suffisamment bien l'anglais.
Donc je dis toujours je perds
certainement des choses. Mais celui-ci
voilà comme j'aime le l'univers Sergio
Léon, Tarentino et cetera, euh Smk
allez-y si vous aimez tout ça. Si vous
aimez bouquin c'est pas mal. Et pour
parler BD alors parce que je lis
beaucoup de BD euh parce que c'est plus
pratique quoi. Je lis de moins en moins
avec mon fils, le boulot machin et les
BD ça va vite et aujourd'hui tout se
fait sur le mode de la BD. C'est c'est
vachement intéressant pour les moms
aussi. C'est une belle porte d'entrée
pour la lecture. Mais les Indes fourbes
euh voilà qui est sorti il y a peut-être
2 ans, il y en a un autre qui vient de
sortir du même hauteur mais vraiment les
Indes fourb c'est une claque si vous
aimez rire sur un fond d'histoire. En
plus, ça se passe au moment des
conquistador. Franchement, c'est belle
claque de bébé de BD, pardon.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur les réseaux.
Ouais, c'est la règle des 3P.
Patience, patience, patience.
Après, il y a la règle des 3T.
Je l'ai pas celle-là. Non, ce que ce que
ce que ce que je dis, je je déteste
faire le démagogue, donc je mais euh
c'est essayer de trouver quelque chose
euh qui a un sens, juste essayer de
donner euh un sens et pas juste celui de
dire parce que vous pouvez pas savoir le
nombre de gamins qui m'arrêtent
aujourd'hui juste pour me dire "Tu es
connu, tu as quoi comme voiture ? Tu
gagnes combien ? Euh ou ça gagne combien
humorist ? Ça gagne beaucoup comique et
cetera. Ouais. tu fais du film, tu
gagnais de l'argent. Ça a jamais été mon
objectif premièrement. Euh et ensuite,
ce n'est pas un moteur dans la vie. Euh
et le seul moteur, c'est la passion.
C'est essayer d'amener quelque chose,
quel que soit le domaine, on peut tous
amener quelque chose, d'essayer de
rendre les autres heureux. Ça peut être
le rire, ça peut être la restauration,
ce que vous voulez. Il y a 1000 façons
d'essayer. Sa contribution l'amène comme
ça. Voilà. essayez au plus parce que
tous les gens qui vous font croire que
ils vont vous aider, ils vont changer
votre vie à travers des décisions
politiques, c'est un mensonge, ça
n'arrivera pas. Essayez de vous faire
confiance, de trouer votre voix et au
maximum, comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure, même si petit à petit il y a
des barrières dans la vie, de trouver
votre axe de liberté.
Fabrice Éboué, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]